foreign
this is kind of I feel like we're in
like a madman episode here but with
burnouts we're in a board room here this
is [__] great yes all white men
drinking here we are I meet a secretary
to come in here and say and I'll say
that'll be all Peggy yeah and wear the
shorter skirt next time I gotta tell you
this is the first time I've I've booked
a conference room in my entire life yeah
well I'm sure we're going to be saying
shouldn't hear that's not normally said
yeah yeah exactly we're talking about
how many drink tickets we are in this
quarter or whatever
we're joined by the hilarious Jeffrey
osmus who has a new special the only
funny white man on YouTube now one of
the funniest Comics
yeah watch it right now Mark Normand has
a hot new Netflix special Soup To Nuts
check it out killing it it's number two
it's only downhill from here
I think that's on like uh like a 4chan
and hey uh Madison Square Garden theater
November 4th get the [__] on it I'll see
you there hello is that still the WAMU
the WAMU it used to be called the WAMU
oh [__] Washington Mutual oh yeah
that sounds better the Hulu there you go
the WAMU look at Jessica Kirsten the
Wawa
are you doing tomorrow too we're out of
here you're done [__]
we may or may not have a rotating group
of surprise guests come in this episode
I'm excited for it I hope you guys yeah
who knows will pop in it's gonna be like
a like a variety show in the 50s with
booze and less cigarettes and all white
yeah
yeah we mix it up and yeah we're
Progressive one
we'll see what happens but yeah here we
here we are in a conference room it's
Montreal is right outside we're doing
the Fest we did a weird show last night
that was crazy that was terrifying sorry
guys I had to see that set that was we
did a show from meta which uh was only
crowd work
the money was bad but he did beat the
[__] out of us which is cool and uh no
we got uh we're doing it for meta so
they're like no Zuckerberg jokes fine
whatever I'm sure musk would do the same
[__] to us if it was a Twitter they'll
do an X show soon
but you know uh they're saying like you
can't they literally as we get there
it's PG-13 and Mark and I just look at
each other like we are trained in pedo
abortion and mass shooting jokes right
that's all we got what does PG-13 even
mean it means like it's so like it's
very opaque it means nothing yeah PG-13
that's great she's all that that was a
funny movie yeah yeah all those great
PG-13 comedies yeah exactly and they
tell you they tell you right before you
go on PG there's no bullying too didn't
they tell you that that's the whole
point of crowd work I know that's the
only fun part of interacting with it
because anyone go to a live comedy show
and go I was bullied I believe it's
probably happened I liked when he
complimented my hair that was really
funny he asked me what I did yeah you
have a great job hey if you lost weight
yeah whatever you're doing is working I
don't understand that I know all these
rules they always try to put comedy in
this weird box it's like when they give
you a corporate gig like just go up and
do four hours clean no curse Sig and
don't talk about the company or money or
women you're like what the [__]
oh but the best every once in a blue
moon you get a corporate where they just
know who you are and they're like they
let you rock and yeah really I remember
I did one for lawyers and it was
literally the comic before me told like
eight minutes eight minutes of abortion
jokes and I was like well I guess we can
just do they didn't give a [__] yeah the
lawyers they've dealt with [__] they
can't act like high and mighty that
makes sense yeah that's true but man I
don't think I've done well on one
corporate yeah you guys do a lot I feel
like I mean they've got money to hire us
they're bad lawyers right they're evil
they got [__] they're like we got
Epstein protected for 10 years but do
not make no cursing don't do any yeah we
defend pedophiles but you can't talk
about pedophiles sure sure
and the worst the company the more rules
they have like I did one for their Farm
big Pharma and they kicked me out I got
fired I got yelled at it was ugly they
kicked you out of the show I offended
the guy's wife like in the first eight
minutes oh God I mean I called her fat
no no but uh but they gave her
yeah their pills weren't working diet
pills that's why they got ozempic was
you made fun of his wife he's like we
need to get you on a cell honey we need
to get a better diet pill but yeah I did
a vibrator joke and she was like oh how
dare you when she walked out and I was
like oh look at this dumb idiot and it
was the wife
it always is someone who doesn't want to
work there it happened to me I did a
Thing Once uh for Delta Dental or
something like you know it's like an
insurance oh yeah yeah and uh oh my God
they were like we were we were furious
and I was like who's we it's like it was
the wife about what just your act in
general it's always a wife who's like
you you're not even supposed to be here
why don't you go home and cook them a
[__] hot meal I think there's a
subconscious thing where they're like I
want to kind of make this about me
because it's not my company it's not my
higher my husband's very successful I
feel kind of bad maybe your husband
works too much you don't feel like you
get attention you found a way to get
attention exactly or she's mad she
doesn't have a vibrator and her husband
hasn't made her come in decades and
she's realizing she's unfulfilled well
they did make Bluetooth so they're doing
so really oh yeah they did all it was a
big drug thing and I went down swinging
I was like you guys are all [__] drug
dealers you're killing the country
[Laughter]
opioid addiction you get taken out in
the headlock yeah you were just
screaming look what you did to
Appalachia as you get dragged off the
stage yeah yeah oh my God don't tase me
bro what Jeff what are you doing while
you're here what shows I've been on the
nasty I've been here for a week for
eight eight days actually yeah I've been
here since last Tuesday oh are you
climbing the walls I've I this town is
beautiful the people suck these French
Canadians are the biggest worst I hate
to be racist but I kind of hate them I
really dislike them snooty they're very
they're all snooty about speaking French
like I'll buy I'll be on the counter
like bonjour I'm like hi they're like
bonjour as if I'm gonna suddenly know
how to speak You're a mile from Vermont
drop the charade clinging to this
culture out of my own hour so it's not
far yeah but they're like I guess they
passed a law like a year ago that
everything has to be in French it's like
a French dictatorship
and I'm checking out and I'm like I
guess I can do this I'm doing
self-checkout in French yeah right yeah
they don't have English options it's
like a law the English people here are
like second-class citizens yeah they're
like really clinging to this loser
Heritage they're like really proud to be
French yeah right Italian's cool but
French I know it's lame I don't get it
but yeah wow that is tough good food
though
it might be the cigarette there is no
like tubs walking around here the women
in in France are beautiful yeah the
women here are beautiful the thing with
the women in France they all they do is
eat cheese and drink wine and they're
what 90 pounds so yeah no no uh
processed yeah all the food's really
natural it's incredible it's kind of a
great place it's kind of good the
audiences are stupid as hell I agree
because they don't they don't when we
were here it was the French version of
the festival we were the only English
show so the audience is like half of
them don't really speak English so every
time I do like a joke that was a little
smarter they'd be like what yeah
you just had to say [__] and then
they'd be like oh okay
there's like a whole scene here of
French Comics I guess who are like
Superstars here really and they'll do
like 20 000 person shows but just in
Quebec I know isn't that weird though
but then they're like you're right next
to America and you can't do [__] yeah
they don't do English comedy yeah it's
crazy
or something except for the host of The
Nasty show this guy Mike Ward he does in
English he's really fun he's really
funny and he got he's the guy who went
to the Supreme Court here for a joke he
got that's him yeah him he talks about
it he like made fun of this like I don't
know maybe [__] I don't know if
that's the word but yeah kid who was
kept saying he was gonna die but didn't
die and everyone kept giving him money
and he made a joke like just die already
or something and they like sued him and
he won though eventually yeah but the
fact that it took his time it took like
year it went to three levels of court
case cases are not funny though if they
made it if they made like a movie about
this he would be the good guy yeah yeah
yeah just [__] die already like he's
our hero yeah
what a credit though yeah the next guy
at the Supreme Court yeah Canada's like
they're like uh passive aggressive
fascists remember there was that
comedian who got an HBO special yeah and
he just won this whole thing was like
I'm done oh I I know who you're talking
about yeah Ellen was like he's dying and
I'm producing named after a famous music
producer yes yes and he just and he just
he's alive to this day it was it was
like it seemed like it was uh you know
six months to live he said he had
terminal cancer yeah it is that was
eight years ago I bet it's a shitty move
because now people are mad you're alive
yeah yeah it's a weird way to live
you're still around [__] you you can't
do another special no what do you do
after that I'm about to die special
you're like dating's weird
well he's like the Sandler and funny
people guy right well now he's like oh
well I'm just although you know wait
what was that premise again well he was
you know he was about to die and funny
people wasn't he yeah and then he
survived oh yeah there's some
differences with that story
people like Sadler yeah he was funny
yeah but that's uh that's crazy and I
mean is he still working do you know I
don't think so I don't think he does no
I think he kind of got I think he
realized that he used his shot that was
his check he cashed it and he's out yeah
fat smart smart I respect that and he
got a special I mean if I had terminal
cancer I'd do a special about it I'm not
you got a lot of plastic surgery and
he's now Gerard Carmichael
still associated with HBO
coming out as gay
it was churning inside me and caused
cancer yeah but my next trick I will be
a trans comedian
have they had one a trans comic with an
HBO well Jay McBride had like a Netflix
oh yeah yeah okay yeah I know she's
funny yeah yeah yeah good egg yeah from
Buffalo which is right around the corner
Albany OH Albany I know she opened for
me years ago and I didn't I kept doing I
was doing trans jokes on stage I didn't
know she was trans I would have done
them anyway but yeah yeah why aren't
these hitting and then afterwards she
was like oh I'm trans and I was like
well I guess that's a compliment yeah
you did you didn't know you right oh
yeah they did a good job yeah you got a
good guy you got a good doctor oh my God
hold on
oh
man
I'm sorry about that until you stay not
trans you gotta fart let it out it's the
end of that chapter right there
I wouldn't mind being trans I wish you
could switch back quickly if you could
like go for a year being a woman and
then switch back I'd like to be a woman
for a year it's very fun the woman who
did an experiment it was like a man for
a couple weeks and she killed herself
what yeah true story what did how was
what did she do to be a man she just
like you know cut her hair changed her
outfit got some facial makeup wow beard
action and
women can't take it they can't live the
life we live gals I just couldn't do it
being a man's harder
more because it's harder yeah we die
younger you're like well why are we
killing ourselves
I do realize how easy it is to be a guy
like you ever you ever just dating
someone and it takes them like an hour
and a half to get ready and you're like
you're just like oh two minutes I'm like
I'm good I'm ready even at this Festival
all the women are like really working on
their outfits and I just throw on the
same sweater every single day yeah I've
showered three times in a week and no
one gives a [__] the best smelling
person here yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah
it's gonna be tough the getting ready is
a real I always say biology is the
biggest misogynist the menstruation the
pregnancy yeah it's like God's the
misogynist we didn't do that I didn't
know if I had designed you I wouldn't
have given you menstruation yeah to put
that in there girl pregnant like Mick
Jagger is like 7 000 years old they got
a girl pregnant who's the Al Pacino is
the real one he's the ninth oldest man
ever I read in recorded history to make
a woman pregnant yeah wow he's 83 or 84.
crazy can you imagine she's 27. whoa
know how weird it's gonna be so cool to
have Al Pacino be your your father and
then you don't but then you don't get
him to be your father he's like for six
years you're like do you remember Al
Pacino was your father kids like what
the [__] I didn't know he was my dad and
he's gonna go back to the old movies
he's like this guy and Godfather right
father yeah this guy was great then
you're like well here's Jack and Jill
and you're like damn uh he was in Jack
and Jill this guy he's got some fun
moments oh wow he's pretty fun of that
oh yeah Simone he's in a couple of rough
ones that one had kind of an interesting
premise so it just didn't work it was
kind of AI yeah before AI it was like
wanted like it's not ex machina was like
that was a good one that was a great
movie no I don't know that one
Mark and I watched too many movies yeah
you guys are moving guys I'm not a movie
guy I haven't I want to see that but I
don't watch movies at all but the way
Oppenheimer and Barbie are it's like
very big in the news everybody's talking
about that's how all movies used to be
yeah there was always like a week like
who were you seeing this weekend always
a battle they planned to put the I'm
sure the studios collabed like let's
let's do a little meme thing together
let's collab on this right at least on
the same weekend well they couldn't uh
promote because of the strikes oh so
we've been promoting for them yes we
should get paid for posting these memes
and it also shows how you know these
companies should spend Millions on
advertising and look you don't have to
it's all yeah the viral thing is what
matters yeah exactly I'm gonna probably
wouldn't have heard if they had you know
Killian Murphy on hot ones yeah yeah I
just want to see what it looks like that
guy eating Jesus Christ you see he ate
an almond every day for Oppenheimer that
was his diet one almond one almond a day
why did he have was he fat and he had to
lose weight Oppenheimer was super you
know he's emaciated so he wanted to look
like
[Laughter]
is so creepy they never do it no one's
ever like all right method actor for
Dahmer yeah
just locked a couple gay kids in my
house they saw what the screams sounded
like with only dramatic actors you're
never like you know Rob Schneider is
never like I actually was a European
Gigolo for a while I really did it yeah
Adam Sandler was a Wedding Singer
he would be good he would be good
no but he uh the cast is insane you'll
just be that's the cool thing about
Christopher Nolan is like he could just
get anyone so you're just you're just
like some [__] a-lister just pops on
for like four lines
do you see Barbie or no I haven't James
was just saying how good it was I I
haven't seen it but people are loving it
Ben Shapiro hated it I read yeah
it was just weird go to a thing you know
you're gonna hate and then be like I
[__] hate
it about is there what man hate oh is it
man-hating really
to be a woman that's like that's like
but the way we're like we gotta get a
Barbie joke out there that's his Barbie
joke he's got to take that he has to be
mad he can't be like I kind of like
Barbie No One's Gonna click on that
thumbnail right friendship hero loves
Barbie for 45 minutes straight no one
wants that that would be more
interesting to me though yeah yeah that
would be great yeah
Jordan Jordan Peterson's like here's
what I loved about Margot Robbie's
performance Jordan Peter comes around on
women for three hours straight
no one's clicking on that I hear it's
great I haven't seen I kind of want to
see now that I'm back in the movie
theater like I saw Oppenheimer in IMAX
and it's one of those experiences where
like you feel the chair vibrating and
the bass and the noise that's great it
makes it [__] incredible oh this is
what I love about going to the movies I
miss this it's just some non-marvel [__]
I just we can't have no more superhero
movies or sequels I'm just talking by
the way can we get those seats in a
porno theater
Herman and lion funny like you're back
baby no it's uh you know it it made me
and also like it's not just as you said
a Marvel movie it's a historical movie
yeah it's like has artistic value and it
isn't just this like lame billion dollar
franchise that they're just like
creating these cookie cutter stories
over and over and it's silly it's like
people we've heard of it's It's art it's
also amazing you think of a war you
think of like badass dudes in the
trenches or something but these are just
nerds who are good at math right yeah
and they ended the war as heroic as the
soldiers were these guys kind of want it
yeah yeah it's also kind of fun if
you're like everyone's kind of bad if
you think if you try to like distance
yourself you're like I'm rooting for
Killian Murphy because he's the star be
like oppenheimer's kind of a piece of
[__] sure sure yeah yeah I mean you saw
it right he's yeah he's [__] up after
yeah you should be well that's good if
you're doing the math in your head and
you're like 220 000 Japanese people like
think about it think about how much we
talk about 9 11. yeah
and then they fled to Hiroshima no there
were people who were at both yeah
because they were close together so
they're like oh go to Hiroshima it'll be
safe you get hit again you're like God
does not want me to live oh you're the
U-Haul like moving sucks Jesus I hate
moving well a lot of the people that got
hit by it like they were okay but then
they died from them oh yeah yeah but
you're thinking about like one of the
great I don't want to do a spoiler but
just one funny thing about the movie is
there was a scene where they're deciding
what and I don't know how accurate this
is I don't know what like I looked up a
lot of stuff but from this uh there's
one part where they're deciding where to
nuke in Japan they know it's like 12
cities and the guy one of the guys in
charge is like I love Kyoto my wife and
I uh honeymoon there so that's how they
get rid of Kyoto and I'm like I don't
like I don't know if that's real but
that's also a weird thing to make up
yeah yeah this guy's just lying like oh
don't get Kyoto I had sex there once
yeah you know the Japan won't play the
movie
oh really yeah they won't play it that
that makes sense I don't know I feel
like we would play it if they made a
movie about us yeah they made a Pearl
Harbor or whatever yeah I'd love to see
we like a little way more people died
and well we won that's why we like it
it's we in the end we still win I did a
joke about it on stage about like how uh
I posted something about like how uh
everyone's like you know in you know
Barbie Rob and I'm around like they're
not saying that in Japan they're like
Barbie oh yeah but then someone
commented like actually the Soviets uh
lost way more people in World War II and
I'm like who who suffered from the nuke
what's the movie about
I'm not denying the Soviets you know
that's such what about is um it's like
well actually during the black plague in
the Middle Ages more people died so it's
actually really not a tragedy at all
after that it's like why is it ever be a
black plague
the real tragedy is opioids which Mark
Norman performed for
exactly exactly
joke about arthritis on Twitter and I
got [__] for that what what how what
happened that's the dumbest joke on the
planet I just said I did an arthritis
convention and the guy after me killed
and I'm not sure if the mic drop was
intentional
and I got like a guy like really man
this is kind of ableist
convention audience was pretty stiff
yeah
get a grip yeah it's also one of the
things that like almost all of us have
or will have yeah it's it's not ableist
you just I'm gonna have arthritis
problems but yeah exactly you have
levels of it too there's like levels of
arthritis
what yeah there's levels of it it's like
an Autism Spectrum
it's so arrogant to think that you're
the only person affected by arthritis
too like the guy commenting is like we
all know someone who has debilitating
arthritis exactly there's no that's also
like there's more offensive [__] that
we're making jokes about that you have
laughed at it's like it's true right
Mike DiStefano rest in peace used to
always say you know I threw up the ball
it landed on you for once and you got
[__] upset shut up I got made fun of
everybody they laugh at a child porn
joke because none of their uncles like
child porn but one of them has arthritis
so that's bad yeah but guess what you
got a cute nephew so look out yeah
you could do it all day like hey you
shouldn't make fun of this like
you know they always say like hey it's
Father's day but some people didn't have
fathers so maybe we don't do a post
about it like but some people don't have
legs I'm still walking yeah you know
like we gotta live our live arms here
also I think those people like I think
tiptoeing around people can also be
offensive I think oh sure when you when
you uh true when you're trying too hard
not to offend maybe that's reminding
them of that even more sure sure are
people who don't have dads mad that I
have a dad I don't think that's
flaunting you're dead are they really I
saw some of that yeah I don't know I
don't do a [__] Father's Day
Instagram post because my dad ain't on
Instagram like it's not for him I I call
him and I go to dinner with them that's
what you should be doing yeah I'm not
bragging like thank God my dad has good
genes and he works out every day and my
dad's still around yeah exactly just
like I like my dad oh man my dad's so
healthy yeah thank God he kept it tight
you know thank God he didn't get into
drugs yeah I know people find anyway I
had my favorite story I did a [__]
joke and a lady came up to me in the
merch line she waited and she was like
Hey look you got to drop the uh the r
word and I was like why she goes I have
a niece with Down syndrome and I go how
do you like the Holocaust stuff she goes
that was great yeah yeah
so what are we doing here my mom was a
special ed nurse she says the word no
one cares it does nothing to it's not
mean at all yeah if you actually care
about them like vote for mental health
it's like funding or stuff like we're
not politicians I know we're not
politicians it wasn't very nice to
people with Down Syndrome either that's
true
I know yeah it's uh people
whatever triggers them in that moment
and it's fine like you we all feel that
everyone feels that but it's just weird
to [__] wait around being offended is
fine we all get offended by things just
don't like just like walk home you know
I didn't like that joke whatever I used
to watch BT Comic View as a kid they'd
be like the white man man I was like
you know I didn't write in right you
know that black half impression sounds
just like me you've been doing a little
too much white devil material on BET
racing like can we switch it around yeah
exactly I'm definitely uh writing in
would be the whitest thing I could do
too yeah dear bet dearest b-e-t
sincerely I was devastated
so how much longer are you here I'm here
it's uh when what day is it Wednesday
I've been here so I'm here for two more
days yeah thank God it's almost over
this is like the party time too so it's
it's been it's fun now hell yeah have
you been drinking heavily here I little
bit Yeah they they like they party here
they're really they're it's a huge party
culture here I don't get why more people
don't do Bachelor parties in Montreal no
it is the big bachelor party for Canada
but they have even Americans like
because you it's like prostitution's
basically legal here yeah it is
it literally is like it's like not but
you go to the strip clubs and there's
like a red light aisle you go down
there's rooms and [__] yeah Mark's out
marks out
here the door yeah
um wow I didn't know it was legal so
yeah someone was telling me last night
they go to this strip club there's like
a row of rooms you just go in and you
get a massage But like everyone knows
what the deal is yeah it's like like a
massage from the stripper please it's
3am please I'm kind of tight yeah I know
she's really good with seven martinis
deep I have a really bad knot in my
penis
you just suck on it a little bit and
that'll come out this is no I don't
think I've been to a Montreal strip club
I know oh I think we went to one in
Vancouver on uh Valentine's Day oh yeah
the big big orange are you fans of strip
clubs I'm not a big fan really I think
it's kind of not sexy honestly I agree I
think it's like also I'm getting too old
like all the women that are so [__]
young they're so yeah and they're just
like good it's kind of pedophilic a
little bit and they look younger than
they are they purposely do that that's
weird Hooters Hooters I'm like I can't
do this she's like I'm in college I'm
like okay yeah I don't want wings
anymore
got one of my favorite jokes in his new
special should I not say this James [__]
it doesn't Gary's got a joke about how a
stripper came up to him and she goes I'm
gonna give you the best night of your
life he goes really the best night of my
life better than the day my children
were born and better than the day I
married my wife and she goes yeah and he
goes all right [__] it let's do this
it's a good night
clubs I did a thing we went to a strip
club when I got new faces this is years
ago and uh they go five bucks a song for
dancing that's a deal holy [__] but of
course I was young dumb and full of
semen and I blew it and I did like 12
songs and I was broke and they were
Ramon 12 in a row at the same woman yeah
it's wild because the songs are like
these techno [__] like they make
them shorter and yeah you don't you
don't I don't know what that break is
I'm waiting for Stairway to Heaven it'll
give me a 12 minute song
you make your own mix you're like it
starts with November Rain let's do this
right yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly but no she got me yeah I think
of course because what are you gonna do
two minute lap dance here like this is
incredible yeah and I blew my whole my
whole profit from new faces which was
like you know a 12 chip right Mark and I
were new faces together the same year
what year was organized career 2013 for
many years wow paralleled each other I
think we both auditioned four straight
years and every year uh you know for
people that don't know about this it's
like a new you get a new thing in
Montreal it's like the in introduction
to the industry whatever and uh yeah
every year I was like Mark you're going
You're like I'm serious I didn't believe
you that you weren't because you can't
tell each other when you get it yeah
yeah I mean we would have told each
other but I didn't but I didn't believe
him I thought he was saying I thought he
was like I don't know if you were like
maybe trying to protect my feelings that
you got it and I didn't and I was like
no I want you to go right but I thought
you were just lying to me to maybe
protect my fiance oh wow but but it
worked out that's amazing you got the
same year no no that year you told me
but but every year mark was like no I'm
not going I was I didn't believe him
right right because I was just like he
should be going in my mind I got it the
year they [__] us over have you heard
about this yeah I got in 2016 they
completely ruined the show and they
apologize afterwards and it's like
legendary they're like yeah 2016 they
really [__] the new face I was here we
were here that year you probably might
have been did you know James yeah
Janelle James was on my show she was
complaining to me about it and I was
like oh should they just people just
didn't go or something they they but the
show didn't start until like 11 30 at
night and then they and this is like a
big deal
I was three years in and is amazing I
don't know how I got it honestly it's
crazy but they they said it was sold out
but it was only half full the first like
six rows of the theater were empty and
then I don't know if I should say the
name of the host but the host was an
older comic who did not care that he was
there yeah and just did bad crowd work
forgot JP mcdade's name and had to go to
the side of the stage be like what's
your name again I wish you would say
wait can I guess if I guess it's like an
older old comic yeah black or white
black Mark Curry no no he's a he's
actually a good comic too but he just
did not care about this show damn
because he has the same
same initials as our first president
I don't know
Jefferson George Wallace is funny as
[__] though funny but he just didn't
want to be there which I guess
but you do have a duty to yeah he did
and he like made them turn on the house
lights at one point so he could see the
crowd and then they didn't turn him off
for like 10 minutes and it was like a
dessert I went up like eighth or ninth
out of 12 and the industry was gone
they'd lie it's a brutal it's a pretty
little thing yeah it was I almost quit
comedy I was like this is it well you
feel like it's rigged in those moments I
remember when I auditioned at the comic
strip it was a big deal for me I was a
young comic and that club meant a lot to
me and I was I was waiting he's like you
have a lottery to audition you're like
okay there's six spots it's after the
Regular Show so the regular show starts
at eight we go on at like 10 15. so it's
already a hard spot yeah maybe 10 30.
who knows so they we stood like guys
stay these are new guys auditioning so a
lot of the crowd was nice enough to stay
out of the six Comics I draw [__]
number six
and everyone before me sucked okay the
guy who's number five before me I [__]
you not he has a nervous breakdown on
stage and he's bombing so hard that he's
like I shouldn't be doing this what the
[__] and he starts freaking out he walks
out of 80 people in the room I'd say 68.
oh
and I'm like my in my head I'm like it's
over for me why am I it's rigged I have
no chance and I just said [__] it I'll
do what I can with 12 people and I just
was riffing and I was making fun of him
and I was in that and I and the uh
Richie tenkin who ran the club at the
time was like I like you for for not
giving up there and wow I wasn't great
oh there we go but it was a moment where
you're like this can't be [__]
happening it's not fair but it was late
night it was just for late night spots
but it was something it was something
wow that's huge how long was the set
five minutes he walked 68 people in five
minutes it was that's talent but
pictures in its own way if we tried to
walk 60 of the crowd in five minutes you
couldn't do it it was amazing he had a
full-on meltdown like there's I think
sure it wasn't his act yeah that wasn't
his thing he's the Meltdown guy oh [__]
he goes on America's Got Talent Heidi
they all just start applauding like he
this is a [__] good meltdown
holy [__] just watching all 68 walkouts
oh my God and you're just splitting with
them please stay yeah it was I wanted to
I was you're like there's nothing you
can do but those moments for the you
know you feel like you only have one
shot but then later on you realize you
realize you get 150. yeah exactly I know
a guy who new faces and lost his manager
so I'll tell you later but it happens
yeah because he had a it was it you know
he's a hilarious guy but it was a tough
setup and the mayor's like I don't know
if it's gonna work out just whatever it
didn't feel right and he was like all
right is he doing well now he's killing
it now oh it's just you can't dump a guy
from one set that shows you didn't
believe him the guy is no longer even in
the business oh good so it was he didn't
know he killed himself he's not in the
business of life anymore yeah
I had a really I got a really bad review
from my show too there was on top of
that this lady left a terrible review of
my set I actually did pretty well yeah
but she just didn't get a joke of mine
she like completely misinterpreted and
she's like
I don't know if I should say is a joke
where I like would know all the capitals
of every country and I would say like I
always say I don't know the presidents
too and or shout out a Canadian Prime
Minister I'm like I'll do it for Canada
tell me a prime minister I'll tell you
something about them and they yelled it
out and I was like white male
like obviously and she's like every
Canadian Prime Minister is a white male
so I defeated the comedian it's like
that's that was the joke lady
yes these reviews
you didn't get the joke that reviewed
this exactly I got reviewed in Australia
I did some gig theater hot crowd great
show and she goes uh the hour was very
good and full of jokes but he did the
classic mistake as a comedian and I'm
like oh no what did I do what's the plan
she goes he opened it up at the end to
crowd work and I'm like
uh you clearly know more about coming
right right yeah
exactly shout out a thing that was
Toronto no that was in Australia she
works for the Adelaide times she's like
huge comedy critics yeah what's your
move I'm like why would an amateur open
it up you know yeah
the bad reviews are the funnest I
because I I don't know why I thought you
said Toronto but it made me remind me of
a thing I did I did JFL Toronto one year
a few years ago and uh I posted a review
because I thought it was so funny it was
like you know he he didn't let up and
his set was a little too dense with
punchline
he's like what are these people doing
they're okay here we go
God damn it what's shaking get on the
mic Ryan Simpson everybody oh okay do
you want to drink glasses yeah what are
you drinking what y'all drinking
beer around two or no I'll do a beer a
Bloody Mary is a gross
we also have soda water bread bowl yeah
we got a full bar downstairs we can get
you whatever you want oh yeah yeah vodka
soda whiskey tequila yeah can I just get
a
ground
I'll do a Peroni you know what yeah
and a glass of ice in the water we got
water in there and oh wait how should we
go okay are you going round two two ass
awesome I'll have a gin and tonic
[Music]
a glass of ice
all right Brian well we lost Brian
there you go get whatever you want out
of that mini fridge there
um
yeah they have the cartons five missed
calls from my publicist Pam loshak right
now
yeah that would be funny Chevy Classic
New York uh angry later I tell my I I
don't know Pam loshak she's a hilarious
publicist but literally the other little
pam pam literally texted me the other
day uh it's just always podcast up but
she goes and of course she didn't call
back and I was like what she goes oh
wrong wrong text oh God we been on the
phone before where she's just talking
she's like oh my God a bird just [__] on
me anyway do you want to do this she
can't be shot she can't leave let a
thought not leave her mouth yeah hold on
she's calm oh here we go oh [__] we lost
her so what's Jacob Brian are you what
you got shows tonight tomorrow I'm doing
that surrounded [__] oh good luck again
tonight or no what's today Wednesday
[__] I don't know you might I think I'm
on The Comedy Store joint oh I'll see
you there is that the midnight one yeah
oh yeah I'm gonna be at that I'm gonna
watch that I might slide by nasty nice
yeah and you got surrounded that's a
night yeah yeah it's stressful as hell
there shouldn't be drinking I ain't
stressed about [__] well well
it is good to go in with a buzz for
surroundings yes no but I've done it
before so I did it when it wasn't [__]
like when they thought of it I did it in
because it started out as a show in the
lab in at The Improv and then I did it
in at moon tower when they were like I
think trying to sell it yeah and now
they got me doing it oh you you know
what it is did they censor you at all
those shows I don't know man but that's
not my problem that's an editor yeah
thank you
that's what I like that I like that I
refuse to stress I refuse to stress for
people I don't
respects good she's like I'm funny and
you don't get to tell me that what's
funny so it's like yeah yeah you hired
me you're gonna get me well money Mark
cut off and they said we could use about
two minutes of that well you did what
made you keep stretching they kept
making you stay here I was overdoing
over 20 minutes all of us were like this
is no that's stressful well yeah it's
not that bad because like at that point
you're just kind of like I'm not it's
you know it's like did you know first
few minutes suck and then you're kind of
like it's all right did you know it was
more than 15 you can feel that yeah I
felt like it was a while but it also it
goes by weirdly quickly too because
you're just [__] you're just I mean I
was just [__] with people I was just
like this isn't how I do crowd work
normally I can't go in with no worry you
know yeah because I can't function that
way so I'm gonna get [__] up I'm gonna
get a little high get a little buzz
there we go I'm just gonna go in and
just whatever are you on earlier late
I don't even know I love that I don't
know anything I just know what I know
they want me to show up at five o'clock
for rehearsal I know crazy what do you
rehearse I don't understand that's what
I can just tell you where to stand and
[__] it's complete like you know this is
what irritates me TV people love to
waste your [__] time they really do
every time I film anything they always
like yeah we need you here at noon until
then I ain't doing [__] till 7 PM right
right yeah and I'm like so I never show
up on time I'm never there for good I'm
not they say be there fine I'm gonna be
there yeah what's the rehearsal like you
get to ask how they met you get asked
what do they do yeah guess what it's
always like where to stand guess what is
there going to be an X in tape on the
thing I'll figure it out yeah I've done
this before it's over here I'm like I
would have found that the light is a
yellow light okay I'll probably see it
yeah yeah I don't know what it really is
is because the festival people do this
too
what it is is and they don't realize
what they're doing is basically what
they're doing is they're transferring
their stress onto you right they want
you they're stressed out about whether
you'll show up whether you'll be on time
with the show so they want you there
four hours early so they are less
stressed right and they don't give a
[__] what it costs you it costs you your
time your free time oh they just
literally the festival is texting me
panicking because Ian Lara is supposed
to open my show tonight and they're like
uh he's [__] uh his flights delay we
need backup options I was like I just
text him it'll be okay they're like we
need a backup I'm like there's a pretty
big Fest here we'll figure it out
we'll find someone we're not just gonna
drop the gig from him yeah right and
then and guess what push come to shove
I'm a headliner I'll just do this yeah
if every comic in Montreal refuses to
open for me you'll do nice yeah
we literally do comedy every night
without you how do you you think when
we're here we can't figure it out they
think these are the only shows we're
doing all year it's like this is the
vacation for us
we obviously we don't make good
decisions like we we're fear we don't we
don't have that the same [__] that
they're afraid of no no that's why you
do this they're afraid of failure in a
way you gambled your whole life on some
on a crazy [__] thing like yeah they
don't they're not those kind of people I
know so we so that's the [__] that
they're like oh my God The Sky Is
Burning we like chill out yeah like when
I got here last week they had like
Walkers to take us to the venues like
I'll figure it out it would be to Walker
and she walked me there they had a
shuttle bus for us and we looked at the
thing we're like it's 0.2 miles yeah
yeah
it's a walking City they thought I would
be attacked by a mob of friends
and one guy ruined it in like 1989 like
Doug Stanhope blacked out it right and
they're like we can't leave these
comedians in their own devices yeah
Sam Kinser was drunk driving in Northern
yeah every Club you go to you ever go to
a comedy club where they charge you for
alcohol and you're like this is good
this is because Vic Henley came here
and he [__]
bottles of whiskey a nice night and they
were like it was it was Top Shelf we
have to have that when he had like 20
sold you just [__] wrecked the bar
yeah if they only give you one drink
ticket you know it's a bad Club every
time it's gonna be a bad Club if they
don't let you drink food it's never good
there's a reason they're skimping on the
the bottom line it's because they're not
making enough money how do y'all feel
about this is my first time here y'all
being hey congratulations I've been here
we're never a new face I wasn't I was a
new face but it was during the pandemic
oh wow oh she did in L.A
which I love because I was like I don't
want to leave the country for what you
did with Sarah Sherman right was she on
it I don't know I don't know yeah SNL
yeah yeah yeah yeah because I because
the next morning I got
so no I mean you weren't bummed to not
do this like I'd be bummed to not do the
thing no I was so relieved really he
lived in L.A yeah I was like I don't
want to leave him you just took an Uber
to do new things
I prefer America like I don't want to go
other places if I don't have to well you
also missed out what did you was Jeff
singer the guy you auditioned for well
he was so this was this guy yeah I
remember Jeff oh yeah he's like that
Edward's got it
but the day the day out auditioned for
him the next morning is when I got the
Netflix thing so I wasn't excited about
new faces I was like well okay oh wow
right right I mean it was still cool but
it is annoying auditioning for a dude to
wear Fedora it was sad to see him get
like canceled because I was like he
really liked my comedy well it was wild
to hear all that [__] that came out
about you know I was like yeah I can't
believe a guy in Show Business was
sleazy this is insane I tell people this
all the time women are lucky
that there isn't a me too for them
because because look though because it's
really about power right and every
almost every woman with power is creepy
too oh yeah so but it's like no one
would give a [__] if men started being
like like you know in like 10 years they
will though no one would care no one
cares so but it's like but but we like
we really wanted to we could get a lot
of these hoes canceled we were talking
about this last
[Music]
still got a Netflix special today
thanks Joanne
I will say this with the same thing I
love about this place is the same thing
I hate about it French the French it is
the French it's very it's very chill
but like but no one's in a hurry the
service is terrible here right now every
restaurant's crazy before I got here I'm
still
I'm just gonna be like [__] are you
gonna help me [__] wow they're like mad
that you ordered a coffee like a coffee
here what why would you what is it like
nobody will tell you anything no one I
knew he'd come with peeves I like this
yeah I smoke cigarette but it's 9 A.M
you work at Starbucks you can't smoke a
cigarette it is fun to see a French
homeless person though yeah you've never
seen I've never seen a homeless person
speak French they're like
oh look like a bad poet he's just a poor
person man it was amazing a homeless
dude walked with me I didn't know he was
homeless because like he said like I
just thought he was like a disgraced
Professor right
he woke up he's like
no English he's like
uh I am the homeless
you the leader
are they homeless it's the only place
you see hobos with scarves too yeah yeah
with a little bit of style yeah jewelry
on they got a couple rings
yeah it is a little it is a kind of a
sexual place though like oh you can feel
it oh yeah it feels like this feels like
everyone wants to [__] you doesn't it I
know it's like everyone you got to get
used to that and like shake it off
because it's not what's happening no no
just friends it's European Vibes
let me look at you with this [__]
it's flattering though but it's just
they just saying hello Yeah you don't
get this greeting in Ottawa I don't know
this is this is Montreal energy for sure
definitely the women here stunning yeah
yeah it's a it's a I don't know about
that I agree I agree they're very very
beautiful here yeah they're beautiful
but like in a different way you know
what I mean it's not like they're
they're like it's like fake tits blondes
porn star [__] cookie cutter beautiful
right it's like I woke up and just
wash my face sure sure yeah
[Music]
thank you
the screwdriver is for right here and
I'll handle Pentatonix right now it's so
funny we're like man the service in this
town sucks
this is great
thank you
a beer for me and a cup of ice for Brian
over here how the [__] did you get a
fancier Hotel than everybody else I said
[__] it I can't stay with the comics
it's too anxiety inducing so I'll I'll
spring for a double there's three levels
the new faces get a different Hotel than
everyone else so there's three levels of
comic rotels yeah oh I just was I just I
thought the Hilton would be the move I
thought I was like but then I forgot
because I think the Hilton until Friday
Saturday is okay that's when I don't
want to [__] be there that's when
everyone's gonna hang yeah yeah Mark and
check into this [__] really
pretty sick I don't mind it for two
nights well and I'm usually a hotel so
now but it's like I kind of I look at
this as a festival and like I want to
see I've been here
well that's the problem because I had I
was originally was supposed to go to
West Nyack well you were here Sunday
okay yeah because I was going to go
straight from cheers oh that's right
[Music]
you might as well get a hand going this
is uh yeah more people are popping in
yeah I'm gonna got the Alienware are you
a gamer are you good
he's got the fortnite skin that is like
that Starcraft guy's computer I feel
like those are their own Starcraft if
you got that laptop you want people to
know you play video games yeah
for no reason yeah
he's like I'm Googling
most Gamers can't bench with James can
bench though I mean James
yeah yeah right and they're big and
they're big yeah there's some big Gamers
a couple of the Asian ones yeah the
white guys are fat as [__] you don't see
fat Asians not really rarely yeah I'm
the fattest person in Montreal I was we
just talked about that he was talking
about you're the fattest guy here we had
a whole episode about you're the fast
guy in Montreal yeah incredible oh yeah
because everybody walks everywhere
probably all right and the food's
healthier they don't use the same
chemicals none of them will break the
rules they all they all just wait for
the [__] life they have cops waiting
for jaywalking we try to jaywalk and
they're like no no no the cops Canadians
are the slowest drivers I've never seen
people obey the speed limit this much
yes if you're in a rush you're like I
got a [__] flight I was leaving
Edmonton and they we're just we're going
like 28 and 40. I'm like dude what are
you doing yeah I'm trying to get to the
airport yeah yeah maybe that's why they
don't have mass shootings is like these
little things this is a society of
politeness they're like no they say we
can't so we don't tools to break a mass
shooting that's just when I was walking
here somebody uh like we were one of
those situations where it was it was a
it was a one-way Street this way and a
and a me going this way yeah and there
was no cars coming so I just started
walking the street and the lady was like
you know something in French
I got a life to live I can't waste time
I swear to God I literally was like I
literally Googled like [__] your mother
in French
what is it what is it it's something the
mail yeah what's your mother in French
mayor is also the c c word all right
and I don't know if it really translates
like they might not mean the same thing
right but it made me feel good I tried
to I kept asking the French Comics
what's [__] in French and they they
said there's no word for it I've just
been saying [__] in English yeah they
said there's no translation for a
[__] [__] in French
[Music]
it really killed
all right
I always think about the fact that that
for the for like most of the existence
the French were were known as being
badasses sure and then they just didn't
help us one time in World War II and
then from and we were just like hey
[__] and that's all we gonna ever
refer they fell off don't joke about
like none of us were alive when this
happened but we if you call French
people [__] everyone still laughs
yeah until we die that's always going to
be the joke and they I don't know if
they really are [__] now but it was
like they there's some badass French
people over there all of Europe
we both lost in Vietnam with the French
and US yeah but they also they they
needed a lot of help uh and yeah lack of
work ethic bad War record armpit hair
man well yeah I beat all of Europe
oh yeah they needed a lot of help to
beat Europe yeah okay all right World
War one they got kind of slaughtered
everyone had to get together but
U.S baby actually basically twice right
didn't Napoleon do it twice
like 20 years
he wasn't even French though Napoleon's
Corsican he's not even French yeah right
and they have some of those badass like
Special Forces and [__] that's what I
mean like Krav Magan [__] I'm not saying
they gotta be more [__] in the rest
of Europe right sure yeah Swedish aren't
and the Swedish are weaker I just think
of them as more chill I mean I think of
like the the what 35 hour work week or
whatever the hell they do not like that
I feel like the French had their empire
and they're like we're done with that
we're kind of like not being a world
flower anymore it's stressful to be a
world power yeah it's a lot of work they
just want to drink wine yeah yeah Greece
was the king of the castle now and now
they've done nothing they invented
tourism they're great they got wildfires
who's next China China's got it oh
they're already they already passed us
probably honestly yeah they probably did
they've tried for a while too but yeah
the Dutch had everyone's had a run at it
yeah the British well that's now we're
talking work ethic the Chinese they work
harder they work really [__] hard
we're getting lazy it's just because
they don't have a middle class yet wait
until they their middle class is getting
bigger and bigger they're gonna have
like that right as soon as they their
next Generation the kids that grew up
that grow up with [__] that once they
start getting consoles right that'll
because they were all poor as [__]
they're like we gotta work hard work
hard yeah they start identifying their
genders and [__] yeah they don't slow
them down yeah we
because don't forget that costs time
talking to your father reconciling
that's a whole that's like a few weeks
right there yeah don't forget we still
dominate culturally like everybody for
sure yeah the American culture yeah that
right yeah they know who Kim Kardashian
is over there we don't know we don't
know their equivalent Jordan is right I
feel like soccer is like sports wise
just soccer is the biggest cultural look
at what athletes are getting paid this
this player I see no no not messy no I'm
gonna do um Bob how do you say
the French guy yeah uh [__] 1.1
billion dollars whoa
I don't think
I don't think LeBron made in his whole
career
Jordan everyone talks about Jordan he
made his fortune from from the shoe not
from playing sure the top athletes are
all soccer top 10 are awesome but NBA's
jumped up like just 10 years ago the
highest played player was Mike Conley
was like 153. Mike James only was the
highest paid player it was just at the
right time I was like he signed at the
right time but then Jalen Brown just
signed for three something yeah which is
crazy it's crazy money their contracts a
guarantee they're guaranteed yeah
interesting football players are getting
[__] now could you choose running
backs I would not let my kids play
football no there's no upside
because even if you even if you have the
potential to be the greatest football
player that's ever lived you still gonna
make a tenth of what and you might do
any other Sport and more of the damage
then you might do a murder suicide you
may be the best running back in football
and he's not going to get paid it's
crazy because yeah we're not gonna pay
you yeah and I'm a Giants fan like this
[__] sucks I love that guy and the
answer yeah it's crazy I love it why is
that bad no I'm just I'm just we got two
Super Bowls on the Patriots in the last
20 years I'm a huge the biggest wow what
do you think look at this shirt I don't
know I empathize with you because I'm
I'm a commanders fan okay and which one
is that the Redskins yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah foreign
that was like old that was like what
they do in soccer they're like just
football clubs sometimes they still go
the New York football
right
right but I found the casinos
dude Jalen brunson's [__] awesome I
love our team so much right now okay do
you have a basketball team or not really
I mean you know we put a gun in my head
I'll I'll say you know the Wizards you
know they've never been good though
really have they have they they made the
playoffs a few times
yeah but not really but I don't really I
love Gilbert Arenas man he was the man
Gilbert was dope you know he was kind of
dumb he was crazy but that's why I loved
him but he was he was that dude like
that I remember that the Kobe game I
just saw some of him talking about that
where uh I do a sport I did a sports
podcast and he was a guest and he that
was the whole episode was about that
game the 60-point game
he I mean I call himself the black
Mongoose yeah
[Laughter]
so there was somebody else in that game
I can't remember to do his name but he
but Kobe because he tells a story about
how in the fourth in the fourth quarter
of the next time they played
he went up there and I was like you had
a good game and then Kobe put up like
40. oh you know were you a big Kobe guy
the [__] though no he was fun to watch
though I look I'm not a basketball guy
right but I was never a Kobe you're a
football guy because the Lakers to me
were like the Cowboys where it's like
yeah they're just the team they were
like the bandwagon team that you you
can't ruining the Yankees people that
ain't from L.A root for the Lakers like
because they were because when we were
kid like my generation when we were kids
that's who was winning
I put it like this I don't respect
anybody that's both a Lakers fan and a
Cowboys fan or a combination of Yankees
that's why Nick's fans are [__]
awesome man we're loyal like in
Minnesota our teams never win well your
team team for a long time but we never
win we're good but we never win the
twins did win the twins did win once
yeah the Vikings won a Super Bowl right
no I've never they've lost four they've
lost four they've lost the most without
winning of any team yeah
the NFC East
did the Bills ever win a Super Bowl I
don't think they did I actually don't
think they did but uh I went to a game
it was amazing because Buffalo oh they
love it they're hardcore I love it I
love them they live in like Buffalo
America's Beirut is it like it's like a
post-industrial wasteland yes Italian
food in Buffalo really they got chefs
man great I mean yeah it's good food
there really good food yeah I I got a
lot of love all there is to do is drink
the food's great sure like you go to
like some you ever been to Billings
Montana I have actually yeah it's like
one of those places where you like this
is the middle of nowhere but the food is
amazing there's a lot of depression
alcoholism yeah oh yeah is that where
Big Sky was oh yeah was that Billings
okay yeah what's my second favorite WNBA
team
I just saw
that he retired from the women's
football league oh Reagan rapper no or
something Megan I didn't even know that
there was a league I didn't either yeah
World Cup they were huge yeah she's was
very famous for the Olympics in the
world cup
is this a big girl we talking about no
no no no you're not talking about the
same person it's got purple hair yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah she said Chappelle's
responsible for all the trans violence
oh okay okay yeah yeah really yeah yeah
pull it up okay I think that's probably
true yeah I think she probably did say
that now that no that she's not that
she's right but then she said that no no
no no what were you saying like half of
the trans Palace is just trans people
live good point like so in in San Diego
the the gayborhood was Hillcrest right
and it's like bro if you were ever there
after like midnight you would always see
two trans people that's [__] oh throw
his hands in the middle of the street
people are just people yeah they're just
gonna [__] each other up yeah but but
especially like when you and that
community and you can just [__] people
like you could just pull up an app and
go somebody wants to [__] right it's
like you're gonna it's gonna always be
drama [__] yeah you know what I mean gay
guys seem to be pulling it off you see
we will run yeah but it's like you see
somebody running out of you know some
running out of an apartment with their
wig and they heels in one hand yeah that
was the best thought of my life yeah
gay guys have a good thing that is
almost like their gym bag right you just
take it in here and you're like yeah
that's the closest thing that humans
will ever have to be in like back to
being proud
yeah just [__] well you can hang it
like a wolf can go to the top of a hill
and just horny and everybody will show
up good point yeah like a parrot like
screeching yeah they call that a steam
room
we've got feelings and reflection and so
if we keep up from being nasty yeah so
true damn like if you if you could snap
if you could get a room full of people
and you could snap your fingers but like
you know everybody do whatever you want
for the next hour snap and they and they
couldn't resist that it would be a lot
everyone would jack off you're right
every single person would jack off
probably everybody
yeah I would probably not try to get
late at the same time when Sandy hit New
York this hurricane all the power went
out in all of New York which is insane
it's millions of people with no power
within 20 minutes I lived in the Lower
East Side which was already kind of a
dicey area 20 minutes
another glass breaking women screaming
and babies crying crazy really bottles
like flying past your window and [__]
wild I love it it was scary we're very
close to Anarchy we don't even know how
close we are right here 20 minutes
without Wi-Fi I'm ready to throw a
[__] punch
no 5G let's go I'm grabbing my high
heels and I'm throwing down look at that
Bill Bird joke where he's like shoulder
checks a lesbian on the street it's like
a big like Bully and he's like why the
hell lesbian's always so mad oh they
deal with women that's a great joke
yeah that's his new special that was so
funny yeah was that Red Rocks yeah
I know so many lesbians that's in
abusive relationships for sure exactly
they no I mean no physically physically
yeah really get physical yeah that's our
thing because because there's no Stigma
they're still in our shoes that's
appropriation
there's no one to be like oh that's not
appropriate or no because most people
say [__] out of your wife well they say
it's a fair fight but it's someone's
bigger and a better fighter yeah someone
straps on the deal though that person
you're here no
[Music]
of lesbians
61 a word they've been hurt and hurt
more than Buffalo Bills fans that's
terrible
yeah and more consecutively too
yeah they want two AFC championships
I always say they should have funnier
names like Memphis menopause and [__]
like that right right Houston hormones
so many people mad about it
we lost we're losing our sense of humor
oh tell me about it we are we take some
well we don't but a lot of people think
they sell too serious well it's weird
because everybody has a voice so they
can just tell them that's the problem so
I just keep doing it I don't I didn't
share like I got all I put my special
out good to see real comedy I'm like I'm
just doing comedy Is that real it's just
comedy I don't know yeah stop calling it
real comedy just I don't know if people
are more offended they're just more able
to share their offense they've always in
the old days they just would watch David
Letterman get mad at a joke and they'd
be like
Youngstown Ohio you couldn't tweet about
it it's just like oh Danielle doesn't
like Letterman said in some interview is
you know when the show was on so it was
like less internet going on and he said
uh he would get bags like garbage bags
full of hate mail and they would just
throw home in a dumpster oh wow yeah
they used to just write letters like
Hank Aaron we hate you yeah whatever
it's like that's what they used to do
that was only the most dedicated person
now it takes way little effort yeah it's
way less effort exactly you can just
yeah it's so easy they have way too much
I mean look it's helped all of our
careers yeah the fact that they have
this kind of access to us but you're
gonna get some of that [__] we should
limit posting you should get like two
tweets a week then you went wasted on
these frivolous things like Chris Rock's
a bit about bullets well they just based
it on you thank you all right like it's
not the guns about me make bullets
really expensive oh
yeah
that's great Rock's got a lot of [__]
Classics a lot of gyms yeah oh my gosh I
don't know see man I'm scared to get
that rich because I don't I think I'm
gonna stop being funny when I'm that
rich it seems to happen I would quit
playing with Jay-Z a private jet you get
less related
you just get less relatable [__] and
also it's like you write this because
you kind of have to and then you get to
a point I think when yeah you're like at
a [__] party with these famous people
and just Comfort it's not just wealth
that makes you less funny I think it's
comfort that makes you less funny like
irritability is an important part of
this like you came in here annoyed and
it was funny
you're not going to be as irritable if
you showed up here in a [__] with a
driver and uh you know it's it's just
different yeah you can't be you can't be
like you guys know how hard it is
purchasing a yacht and everyone's like
oh yeah that's an annoying process yeah
yeah did I remember I went I went to I
went to I went to visit a friend and I
rented a car and then and now you when
you go when you go to pick up your car
there's always what they do now there's
a there's a luxury vehicle sitting right
there where you pick up your car and
it's like for just an extra 25 bucks you
know you could rent this one and I was
like
yeah 25 bucks yeah and then and because
I was always one of those people like
when I was working at the store The
Comedy Store people would pull up and
all these fancy-ass customers like I
would never spend right ninety thousand
dollars on it because that's crazy and
and you know I'm giving me a little
Civic you know with with full package
reliable no but then I rented this car
and I got that some battle card now and
I was like I need ventilated seats
I don't even know what that means it
means like that so when you turn on the
AC oh the air goes through oh that's
nice heated seats too is huge yeah the
air is blowing up the ass and all that
stuff normally you sit in the car you
just sweating on the leather you know
right right
I think as long as you're putting
yourselves that does to me is not making
the difference as long as you're putting
yourselves in relatable situations so
you can still connect to people yeah
separate yourself from the people you
can't live in an ivory Tower of like
money and like like Mark and I have a
lot of jokes about like flying and [__]
like that that's people relate to that
once you start flying private that's you
lose that but sometimes you but but the
thing is it's inevitable if you get too
big you go you have to right because you
won't get to the point where you have to
find other ways you can't walk in the
airport they should be okay walk through
the airport no no right Joe Rogan can't
walk through the airport but I think you
got to keep yourself in check right like
that's the key because you have that
little guy inside you you were you
homeless for 10 minutes yeah like that's
still in you so I think as long as that
guy is in you keeping you in check
you'll be all right because you're still
that guy yeah yeah you can't be like
Colin Joe's like you ever have a private
private like pilot who's like Puerto
Rican
that's a tough one I don't know
College I Love College Yeah we actually
likes him to come on here I'm sure you
didn't answer me you just reminded me
and that really bugged me he just was a
rich guy who popped in my mind yeah like
Dave Attell keeps himself in check no
absolutely absolutely but he's always
like that was a little hacky I gotta
work on that that's not there yet like
that's what you need you don't need the
Yes Man going you're the goat you're
amazing you're Flawless James how often
do I when James films me on the road how
often do I tell you like I feel like
you're too nice to me sometimes where
I'm like tell me that's not [__]
funny right
please tell me I suck I don't want to
hear I'm good it's like yo if you ever
see me with an Entourage just [__] just
[__] lay into me bro there you go you
haven't seen me show it with more people
than that need to be there you need a no
man you need to know guy who's like yeah
you knew half hour kind of sucks man
yeah yeah Marcus arise hired a guy to
just walk around be like you're not [__]
he really yeah and he's been in
meditations yeah
but there is a balance to be you know
you need a balance in this business you
need you can't just you know live a bad
life I mean
I ran into Chris Rock on the street the
other day I was walking I was on
FaceTime and I just hear a voice go Sam
Morel I'm like holy [__] what the [__]
that sounded like Chris Rock and I look
up it's rock and he's like how you been
I and I told him I was like when I'm
like my first actual vacation recently
and he's like you gotta take a vacation
he's like got it he goes even LeBron has
an off season is he amazing
thing but but like that's true as well
he was like you know rock is none of us
would say rock isn't one of the best
ever yeah and he's a dude who [__]
knows how to take time off so there's
there's a balance where like he's still
talking about relatable [__] but he's
doing all these things we're talking
about he flies private he does you know
he vacations he chills he's got a good
life he's got a family I think the
family can keep you relatable too you
have a family kids are always really
everyone's raised a kid talking about
struggle I mean yeah kids are hell but
I'm gonna have a kid just for the
material yeah it's just gonna help my
career
I want to [__] clap them dude
also you don't need to hire I gotta tell
you you ain't [__] when you when you got
major depressive disorder that's what
I'm saying did you yeah it's already in
me it's in the wiring do you do you feel
that a lot of me is that is that a
struggle yeah oh it's a big time
struggle yeah I mean I mean I do drugs
too so you know not not major I mean I
smoke weed a lot yeah and every now and
then mushrooms are you on
antidepressants you ever do that stop
doing them which ones were you on I was
on I did like I tried like six of them
oh yeah so I did Zoloft for a while yeah
Cymbalta I mean yeah and then I did this
uh other [__] that uh man what the [__]
is this but it like it well it all had
side effects I couldn't [__] with yeah I
just micro dose psilocybin that's the
only thing that's that [__] and that and
the NAD [__] that's the only thing
that's made a difference you do you do
you microdos every day no no no like
every other day oh that's awesome but
it's like I was on one one of them made
me [__] it like turned me into
a zombie
one of them made me randomly like I have
to [__] my pants yeah they make you
really tired the one I was on made me
tired I was just tired oh yeah yeah I
could come but I had to like I had to
like tap into some cave
even just masturbating watching my
favorite porn I had to be like
[Laughter]
speaking of not being able to ejaculate
Daniel
what are you drinking
yeah
full bar whatever you want yeah I'm
gonna take one more
I love uh I love a whiskey
just straight up or rocks Scotch neat
and James can you get him another
screwdriver
gay Lennon we're talking about he's you
know we're talking about dealing with
depression here and and he's you know uh
Brian is talking about you know micro
dosing and wheat do you ever do any of
that stuff I don't [__] trust um we
went to a weave store together yesterday
yeah I spoke weed all day every day oh
really all day every day wow yeah I'm
always high you seem so not high yeah
though that's part of the you know the
the the attic solution it's like that's
the thing if you can get away with being
high and nobody knows you're high you
can be high all the time right because
nobody's judging you but yeah yeah I
don't get baked I don't get like my
[__] head
but I can't like I I will you know I
want I join every [__] really is it
medical like a medicine it's yes
it's medicine and I'm an addict it
quietens the the the the the chat out of
my [__] heads and I just and I'm a
nicer person when I'm high hey I'm more
keep smoking I'm more empathetic when
I'm sober if some somebody in the street
was to talk to me I would be like I
[__] dare you yeah talk to me when
I'm just like wait a second behind
somebody's like hey who are you I'm like
I'm [__] great man how are you here
right
I'm just not good at being altered for
real [__] like if I have to do something
I can't be altered I'll [__] it up my I
can listen I can be high
as long as I'm doing something that I've
done a thousand times that's what I need
like if I'm doing something new I can't
be [__] up if I'm if I if I'm you know
if I'm playing Madden or I'm doing stand
up I can be a little high you know yeah
anything that I've done a million times
a day I know like the back of my hand I
can be [__] up because then it's fun
right I'm trying to learn but it but it
[__] with your short-term memory oh is
that right yeah so so
so I was like if you're trying to learn
something new and you hide it's like you
keep forgetting the [__] you was just
told like you don't store it the way
you're supposed to oh no that's scary
yeah it's Comics you need that memory
you need that recall yeah but I do feel
like people who smoke it's like it opens
up a different part of your brain for me
I can't do it but I understand why
people do it but some people got a
problem yeah we don't get high you can't
get high I can't do it dude I get I get
just negativity in myself I don't I
don't alcohol silences the voices and
weed heightens them really yeah same
here are you a happy drunk I'm a good
drunk oh yeah and you would say so oh
yeah I'm pretty I think I'm pretty good
y'all are both pretty positive when I'm
around when I'm around y'all yeah
often but I don't want to bring people
around me down I don't want to be that
me either I hate both [__] that tell
me all their problems
in a positive way it's New York is very
much can you believe this [__] but then
it's like after 30 minutes you're like
but we're good right so these are good
this is a bit I'm working on yeah this
is also my real opinion please your
emotions are
like bodily fluids right that is for
people that love you to have to deal
with like like if like if you [__] your
pants at the party I'm gonna be like who
brought Mark
help clean it up it's not for everybody
that is that's for your loved ones to be
like let's get him out of here wipe his
mouth you know what I'm saying so I was
like people nowadays think that
everybody's responsible you don't come
on a stranger
away
it's different you know we've all had a
dude shoot a hot load all over our face
you drink it right away you don't let it
sit yeah yeah
is called your next Generation there's
no next
generation's not working
that's dead that's just go
let's just goes it's just Ghosts
no one wants to be we've been around the
wet blanket at the party the guy who
Corners you where you're like [__] I I'm
I'm stuck talking to this guy yeah the
guy who's like this [__] guy doesn't
call me back anymore and you're like gee
I can't imagine why you're so pleasant
to talk to we've all been around that
person I was around one of them at your
wedding and I was like this I'm watching
people see this person approach and
everyone is the same face like [__] it's
my wife
all right
yeah yeah that's I had this guy recently
like why don't you like me I'm like I
like you what do you think he's like why
come on you don't like me I can tell you
don't like my like I don't know I got no
I don't even think about you I like you
it's what he was like you don't like
being eventually I was like this is why
I don't like you because he wouldn't
stop I'll tell you yeah and I get it and
it sucks to not be liked but uh he made
me not like him one of the a terrible
thing you guys probably don't deal with
this but at my level like people will be
like I'll follow you they'll just hold
their phone be like follow me on
Instagram like right now that'd be like
a QR code scan the code I'll follow you
like what the [__] yeah let me decide
I'll decide I'll follow you and unfollow
you on the way home sure exactly what
you want yeah it happens a lot
aggressive than a phone number it's kind
of like
yeah yeah yeah right that's the upside
of being 40 now you know once you hit
about 40 you stop giving like yeah sure
you know your testosterone is dropping
and you know you got those kind of
things going on but you don't care that
much I don't need you don't get mad
about stuff like that like me
it's still there like if it bubbles up
but then I'm like yo why do you give a
[__] you don't need friends you don't
even have you're not even a good friend
to your friends
or let me let me rephrase that because a
lot of people make the mistake of
thinking that I'm the a fun friend I'm
not the fun friend I'm the I'm the
friend you call when you have a problem
I'm not defending you called when you're
having a party I know but some people
they they put me in the other category
the ground we all go on no I'm not
[__] going to whatever you'd rather
be the problem friend no there's a
downside to being the problem but you
gotta pick one but yeah but I'm not
built for new people like I'm not trying
to be around 100 people I I mean we got
like 10 more guests coming yeah yeah I
need my environment to be in control and
I need to be less variables I don't need
strangers because the more people you
with yeah I put like this you ever go up
with a big group of people Yeah the more
people are in the group The you are you
the more you're going to have a problem
yeah I agree something will happen you
want to take care of [__] you're
going to make sure somebody get home
I'll go to dinner but as soon as you
tell me it's more than six people I'm
out got it I'm out you know and I'm only
going if some if we know who paying for
what like well that's why they do the
gratuity is guaranteed at a certain
level because people get shitty people
who as you get bigger right right
here we go the coffin more people hello
what's cracking the smallest amount of
whiskey on the planet
all right
hey you know Daniel
is this even plugged in or you just
[Laughter]
like it was like when you play computer
games with your brother and they give
you the fake controller this was so
clearly just a fake [__] microphone
I'm like did they just want my face and
like the thumbnail for this they're like
yeah you're part of the podcast
you see how his laptop's glowing that
[__] don't got fake Electronics
yeah is it is the sound is coming
through just to be sure all right just
check at the level this guy will not
[__] us
you know the last time the last two
times I did I did Ari's podcast my audio
wasn't recording no no
and then and then the episode came out
it was like the audio was just [__] up
go through a clip uh an Air Force guy
said I don't think your Air Force
material
because it's so it's such cake and then
I I feature for him in Denver
and we did it in the green room and this
time there were three of us it was like
the opener me and Ari and we did this
whole [__] podcast and then and the
next day he's like you're not gonna
believe this yeah the audience oh did
you like do it where you could like go
on stage but keep the podcast going we
did that in Philly in the green room I
wouldn't like that I mean you know Ari's
kind of like by the seat of his pants
type [__] right yeah that's what we yeah
so I don't know what his I don't know if
it was like an organized thought yeah
it's just like let's do a podcast let's
just wing it but yeah he's not doing it
anymore yeah the Jew Ari the Jew yeah
no I know James Baldwin wrote some nasty
[__] about Jews I mean he was just like
you know he knew Jews only as like
landlords and like you know that's this
Israelis
no I mean Eastern European Jews I think
there's a lot of type of Jewish
landlords but uh so yeah but then
overall I think Jews you know black
civil rights stuff we're good we've we
link together yeah it was like well
everything
because you know like get the word
ghetto was well that was first Jew right
that's right yeah it was like so
everything every time y'all struggle and
went through some [__] and got
Associated We Came in Like basketball
y'all started y'all was the NBA used to
be you guys are slightly better than us
yeah
no the jury's still in yeah I don't know
but comedy yeah comedy like it's
something about the suffering or the
being like directly like targeted
your talent comes out well it's
culturally I think culturally we have a
lot it's important to be fun yeah a lot
of similar shades are there Jewish NBA
players Dolph Shades was a beast in the
50s
the real big between Jews and black
people that we don't like uh we don't
suffer on purpose like y'all we don't do
shitty we don't do like a lot of things
you kind of asked for it a little you
have to hold the cost but look I'm
talking about like a lot of their
holidays like they got to eat that
shitty bread and like hey you guys got
the same hair can we come together
fish it's disgusting it's wrong I
actually like it
[Laughter]
we don't have any holidays where we
where we suffer on purpose right
interesting like but the Jews have like
a couple of them where it's like okay
now you just gotta be sad today and you
got to eat
you know if you don't have that yeah
like no meat on Fridays yeah
have a great joke about like black
people you know you have the blues Jews
complain we just never thought to put it
to music
it's true
yeah producers
huh a lot of Jews are musicians right oh
yeah wait musician producer producers I
think there were some also some tension
there will we Jews might have not paid
guy was Jewish
picture hash in The Sopranos but
multiply it by a shitload what about
this oh what about that uh that
Netanyahu guy with the Israeli Prime
Minister no no no no the other guy the
was it no matter
Jeff
is a Jewish musician the [__] plays
flutes oh he's a rap modest Yahoo
right that's great oh is he not Jewish
he was acidic and then came back
actually come off real good he came back
he's just like normal Jewish
he's not a Zionist anymore yeah oh
really yeah he came back he's cool I
know
how the hell are you
yeah Ally thanks for coming I hate group
podcasts like this because if I try and
talk too much then it becomes really
annoying right you know but then I just
um I'm just picturing the comments
[Music]
so I prefer to just but then also in an
environment like this I take it too far
because I want to be one of the boys
like when you were talking about that
like I had so much stuff going on in my
head that I'm like I can't say it out
Rogan helped me get over that what like
doing doing when I first did his podcast
I was the whole time I was thinking
about
what people outside the room like what
they were saying what they would say but
but it does it's not good that way you
know no you gotta just go just gotta
roll the dice yeah talk about elk and
Aliens what you're saying you're not
saying pressure sometimes where it's
like but now every time I go on a
podcast I'm just like oh the only thing
that he exists is this [__]
there you go there's also the fact that
they gave us fake mics
oh you got a big girl you know the
broadcast with all the boys
the bootleg uh Xbox controller like what
the hell is this what shows you got
tonight
um I'm doing best of the Fest and then
I'm opening for Curtis Connor
[Music]
YouTube guy yes
is he a comic I do not know what he does
four million subscribers that's huge
that's it he's been doing comedy for 10
years wow
it might just mean that they that they
are unrealistic well you do keep it in
the room
no
I don't even know who we talking about
but I've just been
it's almost like it's almost like
somebody going that dude's gay and
somebody goes well he has a wife and
kids look that doesn't mean
we [__] on YouTube at least for 10 years
you have to have at least some shock
line oh right where it's like he might
not be really funny but he's got
something to work with it's a material
yeah oh he might be hilarious I mean I'm
gonna show you a picture of him you make
a judgment call within one second
what's this person's name
he's gonna destroy us on his platform of
4 million oh that's not what I picture
you see a funny stand-up I'm gonna say
he's more in the alternative
when he said would he would he the vibe
he gives me is he ah let me see it all
right all that stuff
Sarah Sherman yeah yeah yeah
would any would any of us say that the
other person here was funny by it from a
picture though is that fair
what she said to me was not a compliment
but it still makes me feel pretty good
yeah you have a funny face I guess that
works that's what I do you know did you
mean Jewish yeah
no
[Laughter]
you look like you control the media or
something like that yeah Ali went from
I'm concerned with you I think to like
full-on [__] how much is in your bag
s
I could just chat like like we could see
you on stage but like at moments I
couldn't hear but just your face I'm
like you just look like you should be
doing comedy okay okay you know what you
know this you you always look like you
had like you have something to complain
about I I do I gotta can I give you guys
a peeve please norm and I no we do a ton
of peeves on here Norman and I were
having like a very you know had a few
drinks in this last night we're having
like a hardcore conversation in the
street and some guy just walks up to us
and goes how old are you guys oh yeah
you interrupted a [__] good combo for
and we just turned like we were there so
then we go back we're like that our
momentum is gone completely almost guy
trying to lead into it
oh oh yeah it's a weird it's a weird one
yeah
how old are you guys yeah
that that doesn't matter in comedy it's
not even interesting yeah no because you
know what this is what I love about it
too is it's such a it's a bizarre thing
we all do when we never really
acknowledge it but like if an old man
shows up at a you know like if it's his
first year comedy you don't respect him
like oh man God no absolutely
he's a new jack it doesn't even matter
if he's if he 50 if he's your father's
age he walked he walking it over he
could have been in the [__] War he's
an open spot he better know
ledge
he's got a puppet it's a weird thing the
way age doesn't work it doesn't matter
at all like I'm 40 but I'm in the class
with of comics that are all of them are
like 20 25 right unless you're a young
female comic then you get a lot of
respect from sure right right you get
extra suddenly you're getting a lot of
shows
everyone's asking to write with you
she's really respected with her you
should ask the age
how long have you been doing this I mean
life
[Laughter]
actually active
I did have there was a guy when I first
started who was like do you want to
write with me and luckily I was like I
was young but I was smart enough to know
that I wasn't funny at that point so it
didn't even come off as some kind of
advance I was like how pathetic that he
wants me to help him
like he must be in a bad place where I
can help him in someone
yeah of course yeah yeah
no no I also like was living in Long
Beach at the time and he's like I'll get
you a new bird to my iPhone
we should write together
should work on jokes you show up he's
like what's the deal with [__]
[Laughter]
I feel like Marcus gotten some [__]
with that Lima
tell me your pickup line oh I think a
lot worked I go up to a girl and go man
I'll tell you if I wasn't gay
so now you're not threatening because
they're like oh he's gay and then
they're like but there's still flattered
and then you're like ta-da I'm not good
and then they're flowered they cured you
yeah I shouldn't have said cured was
wrong
not a sin she sucked the guy out of you
like like a snake bite yeah there you go
do you think Bill Cosby had a pickup
line or it was just like yeah can I buy
you a drink yeah
yeah
I do it yeah he apparently did the the
assistant would be like Bill really
wants to meet you Mr Cosby he's in this
room whatever oh really he's like you've
heard the Spanish Fly before yeah that
wasn't that his thing
about it on Larry King really she was
like yeah he there's it how you not only
are you a rapist you're so powerful
you're like I'm gonna I'm gonna talk
about it on TV what did he say on Larry
King he just he's like that's what I do
I drop it in the drink really yeah oh my
God a confession yeah Jesus what is
Spanish fly like I know what I know what
it does but what I guess what they used
to call the GHB or whatever that was
like what they called in the 70s or so
it was GHB I think a lot of people would
pick it up from Mexico I'm completely
talking out of my ass I think you're
right but I think you're right but
there's truth to that also how sweaty
are my hands I went like this
I love that Mexicans come here for a
better life and we're like I'll go to
Mexico to get the roofie I guess that
could be pretty good you know or a
better life for some
you should go to the country it's named
after
you don't go to Mexico to get a
Brazilian you know what I mean it's like
in a Brazilian wax and a European Wax
Center in European Wax Center they don't
even have them in Europe what's the
European Wax they just leave all the
hair on no yeah you don't do anything
it's the name of like the chain of wax
places they're called European Wax
Center oh it was a change yeah I feel
like Russian women would like the best
at that right from what I've heard it's
just a lot of like women who are kind of
down on their luck that don't want to
start an only fans they're like I'll
look at other women's vagina
what's the race it's just like random
women
like they'll pay for all the medical
bills when something goes wrong
for waxing
that's what I like about it every
everyone up here is so [__] confident
it it I I envy it but it irritates me
they know they can go to the doctor
whenever they want yeah they were like I
might not get in performance you don't
need to you don't need to you don't need
to look both ways when crossing the
street in the UK or Canada pick me up
and give me free healthcare yeah
you know what it is this is a City full
of people that have all come recently
like somebody make them come yeah
they're out here [__] they take they
rolling these dice because they know
they can go to the doctor they all got
this I want to get hit by a car so I'll
get to go to the doctor for free I Got
This Joy you also check on my moles too
yeah yeah you might have to wait and you
might get like the second best [__]
a guy tried to roofie what happened was
I was at a college party and a guy
handed a girl a drink and she said I'm
too drunk and I and I was wasted I was
like 19. I was like I'll drink it and he
I remember he looked at me angry and I
[__] drank it and I just woke up the
next morning like you're here I got
[__] yeah I have I used to do a joke
about that where I said I have negative
one rapes
but yeah I mean I got roofie and another
dude got roofied with me too I don't I
hope none of the women did how annoyed
that [__] rapist must be he's like
I've wasted two [__] roofies
these random [__] teenagers they're
drinking my roofied [__] drinking
Homer Simpson [__] we just keep drinking
this [__] roofied beer
I wonder if it's kind of like uh open
mics like he had to get 10 000 hours in
he's like he bombed that night
I took a rohypenol oh
[Music]
you know he does like this Avon guard
right right his first album was called
America's [__] you ever seen it you
ever understood it so he has a joke on
there I wouldn't have the confidence to
type that title yeah
he has the funniest joke the funniest
roofie joke I've ever heard but he goes
he goes uh he goes yeah uh
a roofing the girl and I and I brought
her home and uh and I and I and I laid
her on my couch and I you know I tucked
her in you know and I went in my bedroom
and I went to sleep
and then uh and then I came outside in
the morning she was like what the [__]
happened like where am I he was like
yeah so you at my house
um I roofied you last night but I
brought you home and I tucked you in and
you know nothing happened you got all
your clothes on all this other stuff
so uh now that you know you could trust
me
oh it's so good it's funny wow good
twist you know I love a joke where you
don't know where it's going why not no
it makes you uncomfortable to hold up
that's his whole thing his whole cup man
that motherfucker's funny man yeah he is
you ever hear the joke Dwight York you
remember that guy yeah she used to have
a joke he goes to my girlfriend says the
best sex we ever had is when I came in
through the window wearing a ski mask I
have no idea what she's talking about
that's a good joke that's a good joke
man there's some great [__] out there
his name was Dwight York yeah
Midwest guy all one liners
oh really yeah yeah he had a great one
about I'm gonna butcher it because that
one was great and I'm gonna [__] it up
but he said uh if I was homeless I would
just sleep outside a Ticketmaster
you know meaning like say but uh that
happens to be every time people don't
know some people don't because you used
to sleep outside Ticketmaster like get
tickets in the morning
okay generational gaps
like the Apple Store now or something I
don't know
yeah that's a good question he had
another one he said I saw a homeless guy
said we'll work for food so I threw him
a coconut
that's a good job that's great that's
great because you got to work to open
that thing oh
God damn it that's a clever joke I'm so
slow
drinking in the middle of the like yeah
no we shouldn't either we didn't want to
start a drinking podcast but it did not
help our alcohol yeah that was nothing
for you oh yeah just turned it Mark and
I were like we'll start a podcast and it
just turned into a drinking podcast I've
been here for three days and everyone's
been trying to drink with me this whole
time and I'll be like hey man I got
things to do
I'm not gonna drink till after I record
right but you got y'all just ruined it
no you'll be good you'll as long as you
pace yourself I think it's good to go
into the show you're doing
the only way you'll get through the show
is if you get the drunken confidence to
believe that you can do anything I say I
say keep going too [__] hard my
problem isn't my problem isn't
confidence is arrogance I gotta I gotta
temper the confidence okay well then
let's go whiskey that'll make you sad
just when I'm on stage I'm not confident
when I'm walking around but when I'm
about to walk on stage I I'm Napoleon
bro really hell yeah
I've always said you were pretty sure
yeah before I go on the Polly and I
start scratching I'm like I'm gonna die
alone on an island
[__] syphilis like yeah yeah
they made him be a nylon in the Atlantic
that's in the middle of nowhere oh the
quarantine yeah
he's in a cabin on this island yeah
why didn't they just kill him
legs would they [__] love that cut he
he just went and tell you what I'm gonna
go get all of this land and win all of
these battles that we should win because
we're friends
you know what he [__] up Russia Russia
don't invade Russia no the only people
that have ever the only people that are
ever gotten away with it was the Mongols
sure yeah okay yeah yeah well they're
kind of the exception to every Hitler
and Napoleon you know they Napoleon both
try to go at Russia and it's like and
you might beat him or whatever you might
kill a lot of them but like that winner
gonna come and [__] your [__] yeah
so much [__] alcohol that three in
the morning we all thought we could take
Moscow in December by December we're
like there's no way we won't be we'll be
we'll be there before winter yeah
but I'd always just be like what the
[__] is there I don't want anything
there I've performed in Moscow I've been
there you've been you know everywhere
and everything I've done it yeah we did
India for the first time earlier this
year how's Moscow how was that Moscow
was in Mars was really cool it's like
three and a half thousand people and
like everything you hear about them like
in our media is obviously that they're
all [__] backwards but there's in
every country you go to in every city
there are cool people there like the
audiences were really [__] sound they
were young they were liberal you know
they [__] hated their government
they're just they say you couldn't say
pro-gay [__] Yeah
Russia Russia said I can do progay [__]
but I still did Pro Geisha and I Kissed
A bloke while in Russia oh wow India is
the place where they're like not only
can you not insult the government you
can't say that you cannot insult them oh
and while you're on stage and they're
like and by the way there are government
officials in this audience and they are
watching and it doesn't matter if you're
white you will still go to prison you're
not you'll not die but you will go to
prison for a couple of days you'll be
beautiful
but you can't have a hamburger right
like the cows it depends India is a
billion [__] people it's so big it's
like America there's States there's like
if you're an Indian comedian there's
parts of the country is you can't
perform it because it's a different
culture it's a different ways people
it's a different language it's a
different [__] yeah we think there's
like a hundred different ethnicities to
go to India because we've talked about
this 100 I'll get you the [__]
promoters man it is one of the ones
should we do a joint India thing sure
Sam don't do that bro cause you because
you you're I'm afraid for you
because I know I know because I don't
know you as that well yeah but but I
know that you there's a p there's a PCU
that has to Rebel like if somebody tells
you you can't you kind of want to get a
recipe it's a piece of you that's like
I'm gonna say it yeah and then Mark is
my damn matching face you back he gonna
[__] do it do it right and I'm
marching open with I'm gay
[Laughter]
I talk about raping Modi monster
yeah yeah to be there Daly's the rape
capital of the world
you know what that doesn't surprise me
because I spent a lot of time in chat
rooms growing up and it's always these
horny little pesky Indians
hahaha
who are just so desperate to see
something wow and it comes off very
rapely New Delhi is the right capital of
the world there's heaps of [__] heaps
of [__] rape there I I had a show
which I spoke about raping sexual
assault and it's very big in India
because I'm saying if rape wasn't enough
like apparently it's so bad that like if
you get raped in Delhi you don't go to
the police because the police just do it
oh [__] you got to remember India is so
the population of Delhi is something
like 55 million people right it's yeah
it's 10 times the population of Scotland
the country I found it and it's you know
their second biggest [__] say the
crowds are unbelievable the food is
amazing like it's it's a real big
culture shock but it's like if you
thought the Brits were racist to Indians
you should see how racist Indians are to
Indians like they've still got them or
whatever yeah
just they just passed some [__] here
where because the cast [__] is over here
too so like you know how like there's a
lot of brown people working at Microsoft
on Facebook and all that [__] but
they're like hey [__] you I know
from your family last name
I know you're in this cast so we ain't
hiring you they they don't say it they
don't say it like that but they're like
yo you you this last name no [__] out of
here you know you got all the degrees
and all that and so they had to put a
stop to that [__] or they're trying to
but they [__] they brought that [__]
over here I like we were some of the
shows and I love the shows I did that I
cannot wait to go [__] Bike Dude
highly like like it's weird that it's
different it's a culture so it's a
beautiful you made a lot of rubles
they it's it's
they at the end of the show they click
their fingers right when all the staff
are out and these 20 people I've not
seen but not soundtex not security come
out in like racks they're all darker
skinned and they start cleaning up all
of the chairs and stuff so because me
and Kai my support like we thank all the
staff for every venue we go to regard so
we make a point to like go and thank
these people and the people who are with
it like oh don't don't feed the pigeons
like
even like trying to I'm really making
the point to engage with them even they
when we were like hey thank you very
much they were like whoa hey
because man they are they are poor and
you're a white man talking to them if
you're doing that that's the worst thing
that could happen
[Laughter]
yeah and you're a Jew they got a New
Delhi
yeah colonized
in like uh
like any of their Cinema no the
Bollywood no but yeah I've just watched
the probably one I don't I because I
hate musical [__] so every time I watch
an Indian movie it always starts out as
a dope movie and turns into a musical
right right they're all music RR I watch
RR
was dope what that's a lot of [__]
is
though the opening scene or a stuttering
Pirate no no no don't sound like a dog
there's a British like the villain of
that movie the opening scene that guy is
he's in a village and I forget what the
[__] he was mad about but uh but he he
wanted to discipline one of the Indian
people and he told one of these guys
like take care of this the guy went to
go shoot him he was like he was like you
know how much it costs to make that
bullet and ship it from England he's
like no beat the [__] out of him don't
shoot him he ain't even worth the bullet
I like that that type of [__] yeah yeah
that's cool that's capital and then and
then they went into like songs
you want to be
we keep talking a green dictator
there's a lot of good martial arts and
[__] but it was a lot of dance yeah is
it like three hours I'm not a fan of
that and for for the country that is not
that big a fan on the homosexuals gods
they love blokes best friends loving
each other holding hands in public oh
really dancing together and you sure it
came out it's just illegal they're like
yeah
why wouldn't
[Music]
no just because I when I was this was
years ago government jokes when I was
when I first started it was literally
like my first week being a door guy at
the comedy store and he showed up
and he was like and he was like I'm he
didn't have his ID he didn't have his
passport nothing he was like I'm I'm
this guy and I'm like I'm sorry I don't
know I don't know what you're talking
about man he was like I'm the biggest
comic Andy I got more followers than
Kevin he showed me all that [__] and the
manager came over and was like yeah yeah
you need to go back to your hotel again
he was like literally the biggest comic
in the world you know he really did he
showed me he was like I got more
followers than Kevin Hart and he showed
me and I was like damn I'm sorry man
like I don't I don't the manager I don't
know what to do this is my first day my
first week I don't know what to tell you
oh that's like when Bill Burr went to
LOL in New York and they he went to the
LOL Club in Times Square and they like
they wouldn't let him perform there
after he headlined masses and Square
Garden that night they're like he's like
I'm on the wall and they're like you're
not past here you can't do a spot he
said I'm playing the garden yeah they
wouldn't let him on
did he not know who he was no they
didn't know
how much do you love [__] stand up
that you do Madison Square [__]
garden and then walk past a shitty the
worst Club in the yard
and he was like I'm Chris Rock and and
he looked at the this is how little they
cared about stand up there he looks at
the bartender and the bartender's like
all right fine
Chris Rock fine oh my God clueless I did
I went to London with uh with Rogan and
did the O2 Arena so we were doing the O2
Arena the next day
and I I popped in at this place that I
always saw it online it was like the
secret top secret top secret room and I
went and I walked over there because I'd
known people that were there last week
they were like yeah they'll pop you in
over there so I walked over and it was
like hey can I pop in over here and they
were like we don't do that
I was like what do you mean it was like
yeah we don't do that here
yeah apparently once they then they they
can be [__] [__] they put it up
online
was over doing some shows and popped and
stopped it could be like let me jump on
and they guys were like no oh really
yeah yeah they don't know so I'm like
wow how is someone running a comment up
over here and they don't know anything
about Comics I know it's weird welcome
to London baby welcome to Comedy oh I
didn't get mad about it but I didn't I
did I was irritated but I'm just like
you just you shouldn't be running this
because it's not like a do you know who
I am type [__] but it's like you should
know who I am I just do too right I just
did the [__] Arena over here and you
and you and you're you're [__]
clueless if you run you won like the
main comedy club in the city but it did
you're right it's to your point it's
like we [__] Giselle and then we're
like let me go see what I'll go eat out
Kathy Bates
and then Kathy Bates is like I'm good
just masturbated
misery was on TV the other day that's
such a good [__] movie people want to
look back at this episode of this
podcast like that was the end of a lot
of careers
[Music]
I've said it every day I've been in a
complained to you about it every [__]
day I will never forgive the [__]
Canadians for letting
Daniel there's only two genders
I
was like greeting you in French yeah
Mr if I should take it as a compliment
like I seem like maybe I could be French
passing like I look like maybe I have
French features but if it's happening to
everyone I'm like I'm like look at my
[__] no it's like
yeah
you're the enemy that is the one
positive about this place is like
everyone's like effortlessly beautiful
because they're not trying to be
beautiful you know what I mean that's
what that's what make everybody here
sexy they're not they're not trying you
know somebody with too much makeup they
they should their hair is not overdone
they're not wearing some designer [__]
they just sexy yeah walking down the
street like I own this [__] I
got free healthcare yeah yeah
you like French women I don't know I
guess I do now yeah I didn't know that
before they all look like they worked
out this morning too
look like they don't care if I notice
them I think it's also like the weather
because it's kind of like warm and humid
everyone's just wearing kind of like a
sexy top that looks like it's an indoor
like just at home top that they've
brought Outdoors slightly glazed like a
like a glossy magazine sheets how many
eyelash extensions have you seen since
you've been in Montreal it's a good
point none good point oh I hang around
with some gays so I've seen affair
because they let me say [__]
that's the same reason Mark hanging out
with black people yeah
man we're pounding a black guy
definitely the first word every time a
lot of these words have been said in
this conference room
so you can't call Bill that
oh man what
this is the best this is comedy summer
comedy summer camp yeah this is the only
thing this is the only thing that makes
it worth it to me yes because I
I know nothing shows are sure nothing
against just for last in particular I I
feel the same way about every Festival I
think it's just a way to exploit Comics
that you know whatever but you know it's
also a chance for us to like be around
our tribe we don't get a hang like this
anymore
because listen when you're back in your
own City you're around comics but you're
all also around the ones that are like
bitter and like negative you know what I
mean like to be the chance to be around
comics that are all like on the upside
and the positive and like secure in
their careers it's a whole it's a whole
different thing even the people I don't
like when I see him here I'm like hey I
love that they're cool here yeah I was
like being around my own people sure
yeah yeah because you know what it is
you do this long enough you you relate
more to comics than you do to your own
family oh completely you know what are
you kidding sometimes I'm on I'm on the
phone with my own mother and I'm like
jeez
[Laughter]
yeah like this is not interesting at all
I've heard the story five times you
ain't punched it up yeah
you know my mom have a special she goes
how long
how long is it but you around comics
like this conversation this conversation
could go on forever Sam's over there
trying to find a point to like stop it
is he are you the guy who stops it is
that yeah yeah do I have to wrap this
you mean no are you the guy who's always
looking for the time to stop
how many people you know in comedy I've
never had a full conversation with you
I'm a fan but this is great with the
pods because you hand somebody a mic and
now we're stuck with an hour right yeah
you almost become friend through
podcasts
the first time you meet a friend you
interview each other for an hour and
they don't see each other for like three
weeks and then you're like hey remember
we met at work and now we're buddies
it's very surreal everyone heard our
conversation yeah yeah the public
decided that we were friends I've now
decided to invest in our friendship the
public approves office you know you know
that's what's funny is I think I think
it's like it's one of those it's like
just like jewishness
no it was like because once you meet
somebody and you know they're a comic
for real like after you talk to them and
you can tell they're like really
oh now you're one of us right so you
invited to the [__] to eat the shitty
bread
is that what it's called not to the flat
Drive yeah yeah but instead of wandering
the desert we just wander through shitty
Open Mic all right we're here we made it
we're in Montreal we did it the promised
land here no uh you just thought
somebody would have made an exception
yeah right or something like if you
married you can put some butter on it or
something no you put butter on it oh you
can yeah you can do it you can spice it
up you put horseradish on it yeah yeah
there we go oh you've been leaving money
on the table
I do love that Jews can be like spies
too like she unbales herself
so it depends on who I'm with let's play
it up yeah my my dad's Jewish
they say it doesn't count but yeah we
still look we claim who we claim yeah
yeah I mean if you're successful it
didn't count to Hitler right didn't it
wasn't he mom only did he say you had to
be really yeah I thought yeah I think so
oh that's true that was because it's
because his dad was Jewish yeah because
he couldn't be like they're Jewish
because he would have been yeah exactly
so you're saying I could be Hitler you
could be you could have a lot of power
this whole time I thought it was Larry
David I assume you have a micro penis so
yes you could be hitless you are
no it's uh this pisses me off man what I
don't know because because I gotta go to
this [__] five o'clock rehearsal for
this 10 o'clock set oh true I have a
[__] 10 30 a.m call time tomorrow for
a 7 30 p.m [__] Gala No yeah I'm at
the same one oh yeah we're at the same
one
I'm not staying there all day are you in
this variety one of the [__] Peter's
ones the comics to watch no no the
Russell Peters Gala the gala okay yeah I
think we're in the same one okay so I'm
not okay because I ain't I ain't getting
them I don't even get up at 7 30. seven
years at 7 30.
7 30 p.m show yo yeah I don't get up 10
30. no I'm going at [__] drink until
4am tonight bro you're talking about 10
a.m I don't do nothing before noon no
never no I don't schedule nothing before
noon and he ain't no it's funny too your
people your agency and all these people
they'll try make something like super
important and try to like oh well but
they only available at 8am then that
ain't happening I became a comic so I
wouldn't do things before noon that's
one of the main reasons that's why I
hate when Comics do that Sam I'm all I
will be forever grateful you didn't even
hit me up till 1pm
you ever since the last minute thing
together Mark and I are [__] sloppy
we're not together but yeah the comics
are always like when I meet a comment
it's like can you do my podcast oh yeah
sure okay so yeah we meet it we meet at
8 30. that's crazy I'm not gonna be you
I mean I haven't been a great example of
it here but I'm not going to be funny at
eight in the morning sometimes I'll have
to do like radio interviews and they're
even 11 in the morning I'm like I I'm
not I'm not no you're not the radio
interviews pro athletes do they play at
11 A.M basketball is at 7 30. right
you're not up yet let us get up unless
they go to Europe you know like NFL
Europe yeah I guess right but yeah
you're right but normally not I'm never
I'm never ready for it it doesn't work
every time a club asked me to do radio I
want to [__] murder somebody I know I
know it's brutal I'm finally now I'm
getting to the level where like I could
just say no you have to talk after
Living on a Prayer just play that's just
classic rock station so I heard you went
to a wedding last weekend
that was Bon Jovi here's Jeffrey
interview with somebody that all they
did was just read read your uh your bio
yes yeah like I saw I'm a huge fan so
assistant you're from Chicago yeah what
I'm supposed to go on for me do you ever
get the cards that they've the only
resource they've done into whatever your
[__] stand-up is they've watched I
clip off your stand up and they will try
and set you up for nine-year-old jokes
that you've already done yeah they'll be
like so I uh heard that your mother cut
you masturbating the other day and
you're like I'm 31. like that is from
yeah
some Comics that joke still works I
still live at home George W bush right
here so you're not against the war on
Iraq how is that
some of those morning shows you're just
like these dudes well you guys are
legendary for clowning trolling them
well the weird thing is if you do
everything they don't want it's good you
know like oh my problem is just loses
their [__] I remember she booked me on
Ari melber and they were like it's an
MSNBC show and I'm like why are you
booking me on this show there's gonna be
a nightmare and she's like it's good
it's good ratings I'm like all right so
I'm in the green room and I'm just they
change every topic at the last minute so
I'm like I'm just gonna burn a hole in
the room [__] this yeah and then and
then he does the thing where he starts
trying to make me look corny and I'm
like I'm gonna ruin you this is live TV
yeah you're the one who has the career
hey I'm gonna make this uncomfortable so
I just start doing Epstein jokes and
they're just like mugging camera like
[Laughter]
just like I mean this is for you this
says I don't give a [__] you're the one
with the like The credibility right
right I got a fans I'll never be here
again
I know I just assumed but it's like when
they some of those guys have that thing
where they like they can't just let you
shine they kind of have to go Toe to Toe
with you and make you look corny and
you're just like I [__] hate the
radio jockeys when it's like there's
some long-suffering woman who's been in
this job for 20 years and she's just
been past male co-host who was then
fired for sexual harassment who's fired
for sexual harassment she's on like her
seventh [__] guy and he's just not
been caught yet
and he's just there just there he thinks
he's funny like you are and he starts
picking these shitty [__] hot jokes
and just her dead eyes are like
there's seven minutes try doing it every
day for 25 [__] years
bury you on TV and you're like dude
Letterman and Conan try to make you
shine like this is such small dick
energy just set the person up to succeed
on your show yeah but you know you gotta
let people be you know they they're the
king of their little kingdom that's what
it is I Ruled weather
[Laughter]
I want everybody about hurricanes 30
minutes before uh what the [__] do you
do make fun of it
that's all I got yeah radio is so
[__] sad it's barely hanging on by a
three okay you get a good one yeah you
get a great answer where they they shock
you you know these guys that was great
really yeah and then I went upstairs and
did one that was awful like I did like a
few but the first guy was [__]
awesome so every once in a while there
are still people that give a [__] and
take it seriously but you yeah when you
get the cornball you're just like this
is like hell it's like a bad date it's
just like you're just like it's this is
a waste of my [__] time right yeah
like and then I go to the like because
I'm I'm so against it like every time I
get talked into it I go to the show and
I go who here he heard me on the radio
and when and I record it and I send it
yeah yeah
really because it doesn't work it
doesn't work they insisted it works
sometimes it works every like I probably
I've probably done radio like a hundred
times yeah and it's it's worked like
three times and not like drastically
it's probably 10 people I probably sold
like 25 tickets some cities it pops I
mean some cities like that it's usually
like cities that have are still like
living in the 80s yeah like you're like
[__] Illinois
I did a radio show in Tampa once and the
guy this is like a shock shock guy and
he goes you ever just bang a skank I'm
like that's my leading this is my
lead-in I know that guy but I know
that's skank
look this is my kind of show yeah I feel
like I've never just bang this guy I
call them afterwards
check up on Facebook it was like banging
me is what made the mascape
is
me there was a must join you know
beginning with how's the strike affected
y'all oh yeah it hasn't affected us I
had a show I was working on but other
than that I mean like it's not like my
career was not going well enough to be
affected by this strike I am not
affected by this I am absolutely going
to go to [__] Hollywood in the next
six months and be like I'll cross the
picket line I'll do it I'll ask what do
you want I'll do anything
it's the only one
yeah but he's gonna be the new
Spider-Man yeah
yeah Panther like it's gonna I'm doing
it all
at all Arts nope he's doing it the
Union's not International how does it
work do other countries they don't care
it doesn't matter right okay I'm not
sure
you know this is bollywood's Chance
throw some films in America they gotta
have some true crime [__] yeah yeah a
true crime musical yeah there we go
now we're talking how about that Go-Go
Beach guy you know that like every it's
so [__] up now the Long Island guy
yeah whenever a murder happens like you
know like Netflix
like bidding for who gets to write for a
true crime for sure it's kind of sick
yeah
Gilgo Beach killer he killed four sex
workers recently and they fought like 12
or 14. yeah more probably but that's
confirmed I think but then uh then there
was like a toddler and he was like that
one's not mine
yeah
they're Anonymous yeah I feel bad for
him but at the same time
no cause I'm like bro why are you
walking the street like just you can go
online with it like well I think I think
they're escorts yeah
no he one of them his wife was out of
town yeah well one of them he met for uh
dinner and and he was like talking about
the murders with dinner he took her to
dinner yeah
bragging about the murders to the point
that she like he didn't say he did it
but he was like he was talking him up
with like his eyes lit up and she was
like [__] and she like got out of there
so she didn't die
that would be a weird thing to pick up
on a day what your interest why did you
see how many times
like it was like a world record the
mountain they're saying he said his
cardio must be amazing to have that man
it's a huge [__] why did he take it why
did you take her to dinner shouldn't
that have been the first suspicion I
think some of them are probably like you
know I want to meet you first I followed
my friend she for like a very small
period of time put herself on one of
those websites where you like pretty
much just go to dinner and get money and
I I was sitting outside at the
restaurant just watching and um it's not
it's always just like dudes who are kind
of like uh misogynistic and just like
sad where it's like at the end I was
following them and they walked to the
car and he was like can I hug you and to
imagine like the opposite of that is
like they're either really shy and
awkward or they're just like murderers
I've done that without paying women to
go to dinner
like can I kiss you on the forehead
I can lose you that you
need to pay for your food
I'm married with kids too I have a
friend who's uh who was doing sex work
out in Australia she was doing a degree
and everything she shouldn't have like
two clients but one of her clients would
fly across country to like do her a like
type up her University work for her
cooker dinner clean her house everything
and never Factor never kissed her
nothing he just he would pay for himself
to go there be a servant for her for
like five [__] days and then go back
and that was his [__] King she was
like it's the best
she's like I never saw his dick we never
[__] kissed like some people are just
we need to look at lonely who's like his
Kink is to do all our work for free
those those fin down people were like
their Kink is to to like to be almost
broke but if like women yell at them and
stuff no no like to like spend money
they don't have on oh wow they want to
be they want to be financially abused so
they want the woman to be like I need a
Gucci bag and he's like I can't really
afford it like buy it [__] just
buy it that's a kink that's a king they
should just do comedy Pig
[Music]
I'm sorry bro it's like bro you know I
feel like Mark is just using Jew as the
punchline getting egregious here I'm
trying to get you guys fighting together
silence he's like Jew oh my God damn it
best
should you be so good like shouldn't you
be an expert in masturbating by this
point well it gets old you've done every
trick no it don't get old to me well now
what if you had money to pay a woman to
do this stuff would you do it
oh I mean because at the end of the day
you you pay every woman true true right
I mean so it is yeah like you maybe
maybe not maybe not directly but it's
like because because it's weird that
people go oh it's legit if I if I talk
you into going to dinner and it's like
you still paying for dinner well I talk
to you and go on a vacation you're
paying for vacation it's this real thin
line between whether it's like sex work
or just courting you know that's true
the same with uh sex work and porn yeah
when I film this it's porn right but if
I [__] in a car ain't no job
all women are sex workers when you
really think about it
well I think the main difference Brian
is is between sex work and dating is
that they're not [__] other dudes
while they're dating you that's why I'm
really into it right yeah right it's the
exact same but I just mean ain't no free
[__]
that's like there's no such thing as a
free law no this won't cost you
something it's like the other economics
it might not be it might not be money it
might be money but if you're trying to
get laid it's gonna cost you something
yeah I don't know
yeah you get laid for free is there a
free day yeah I think most sticks are
free they're easy to come by no no
listen no dick dick is like that jar at
the [__] club where's this condoms in
it yeah it's like dick is just available
in the bundle
[__] it the market value
yeah bars
for Yogi bars
Good's never free because as a woman you
you pay for yourself to look better to
attain that there we go
up and you gotta buy a razor to shave
your legs
you doing all that [__] anyway
no that's gonna cost you your heart
being broken
now we get serious how everyone starts
crying when have you ever
had some amazing dick that's just yours
oh like you weren't sharing with another
lady right anybody that's [__] like
that is [__] a bunch of people
yeah that's how you get that's how you
get that good at [__] you can't just
you ain't just come out the womb like
that interesting it like level 10 Vic is
not I know I know this guy with a great
dick and he's terrible in bed
all right all right sorry it's good to
see you again
y'all are [__]
super straight
yeah that's great I should just say but
when I was when I was single I would
make sure like every two years
just to double check really I can buy it
they're messy in my room like I just
[__] attractive contracted to [__]
but like
the beach I'm gonna be a ripped guy and
I'll be like I am just staring at him
right yeah sure and so then I would get
Jordan the kids well beautiful people
are beautiful people yeah yeah you can't
yeah but sometimes you said are you so
but not in India
like a bunch of the answers no no you're
still a dude we've all taken a big poop
and been like if it felt that good
long hard and brown yeah Hollywood
how are you gonna edit this
yeah oh no I think we think we'd I think
we didn't go too I don't think they were
there
there's a lot of knocks and bangs and
the mics
person yeah what kind of the
anti-semitism
oh all right well we should wrap it up
anyway yeah everyone got some uh
I'm BS comedian on socials my nephew
special will be at the end of the year
hell yeah
yeah
no I haven't named it um
no pussy's free
all women are sex workers yeah uh yeah I
think I think I attentively I'm gonna
call it looking good but we'll see
looking good there we go I like it man
Ali what do you got coming out to lunch
I'm doing
you got a pod
okay no you start resting [__] I
stopped it why because it was bad I
agree all right
any road dates or anything you want to
play not particularlymakovsky.com
shows go to the website what do you got
Dan oh just [__] dinosaurs
Google Daniel Sloss jeffreyasis my new
special on YouTube the only funny white
man please watch it yes very funny go to
whitecomedian.com for my show I bought
that URL years ago
whitecomedian.com
that's hilarious uh we got a lot of
dates coming up you know Albany Vermont
uh Northampton uh the garden Providence
yeah MSG theater let's go Chicago
Theater Toronto York Bethlehem
Cincinnati Columbus India ton of [__] uh
see you guys on the road oh in Australia
just announced all over Australia
because of you [__] are you
talking me in there and you talk me
double into it so I'll see you in
Australia in November tickets on sale so
uh oh no I've just I've also got a I've
got um Netherlands promotions for you
both oh okay there you go let's do it
Mark uh Mark Norman's new [__]
Netflix special hey special
for the folks at home it's online and um
[Music]
oh we could have snug it through [__]
we could have gotten it through probably
did you have to pay for the flight
and put them up and plug some digs plug
some gigs
all kinds of gigs Denver you name it
it's all it's on the website yeah it's
on the west bronsoncounty.com There You
Go comedy thanks listen we might be
drunk what an app Montreal Edition jfl's
youth career [__] the French Kiss our
ass
and thank you to James Webb for coming
up and doing all this dirty work for us
because our producer Matt Peters is
somehow banned from Canada so yeah he
ran over a kid in 88 but
yeah he's a [__] but we love you
guys you pulled through thank you thank
you
oh my God
[Music]
house and I get down in the same way
s
[Music]
up to lunch here in New Orleans this
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]
thank you